how's it going everybody i i almost
didn't want to do this story as the lead
for a few reasons one i think a lot of
people are are you know commenting that
the story about a local restaurant being
attacked by establishment media and
democrat activists isn't that big of a
deal i saw some one person said oh must
be a slow news day no this is just
substantially more important than other
news i mean we've got some big stories
we've got san francisco is going to be
an act they've announced they're
launching their their vaccine passports
i mean that's a huge story
uh it's the third city to do it i think
that matters i think it matters a whole
lot
but this story about the restaurant
really really got to me i don't i don't
want to do it for the other reason was
that
drawing more attention on some
working-class dude and his buddy who
just want to serve burgers and and
chicken wings i'm i think
it might be bad for them you know but i
i can't ignore what's going on with the
psychosis of these these democrat media
establishment types and and i'm trying
to figure out like how do you describe
these people they're authoritarian
psychopaths all right the gist of the
story is
some guy gave a quote to local media
about his rising costs of food and
because of inflation
it was not political in any sense of the
imagination
local gop
highlighted the story calling it by
inflation
now what's happening is
several different democrat aligned media
outlets have called the restaurant liars
insulted them they're mocking them and
they're driving a harassment campaign at
them to the point where you know i got a
call i call i called them for a comment
to clarify like what's going on because
the gag is that their mayonnaise was
their guzzling mayonnaise now people are
going after the business they're
slamming them on yelp and these this guy
didn't even do anything he never
criticized biden he had said nothing
about it he just said oh yeah
inflation's been you know kind of
intense we're spending you know 200
bucks more per week on mayonnaise and
now to see what they're doing to regular
people i'll tell you why i think the
story is more important
than a lot of other things it shows you
you have an authoritarian despotic cult
that will destroy a local business
simply because
something they said that was true and
factual
threatens their regime their their their
stupid system yo biden's responsible for
the inflation for a lot of reasons this
guy didn't even say that now what's
happened you get huffington post the
independent e100 going after a small
business and calling them liars and
driving these lunatics on the internet
at that at this restaurant
and now they're telling me they're
worried like is this gonna is this are
we gonna get you know shut down because
of it are they gonna come after us it's
gonna hurt us we don't know what's gonna
happen next
dude seemed like he was genuinely scared
because he never experienced this and
this guy's totally apolitical we gotta
talk about this
about how when you get effectively brown
shirts going around beating people into
submission what that's going to lead to
so we'll talk about that we'll talk talk
about what's going on in san francisco
with the other side of the authoritarian
coin and we're being joined by kyle
becker ceo of becker news how's it going
man good tim thanks for having me on uh
it's been great and uh i look forward to
talking with you during the show right
you want to just do a little brief
introduction like your work what you do
yeah um so i uh run my own website
beckernews.com uh you can find me on
twitter at kylan a becker
and you know i've been in the media for
a while as former fox news uh associate
producer and writer and uh you know
i've worked in media for a while
viral media um expert so
cool that's kind of a perspective right
man thanks for coming all right man we
got ian before i forget i think a lot of
these writers that are writing this that
are like taking things and printing them
out of context at first i thought they
seem psychotic because they're less
they're not critically thinking they're
kind of stupid you could argue but then
i'm thinking maybe they're just dizzy
because if you take the best pitcher in
major league baseball in the world and
you spin him around really fast for a
long time and then you ask him to throw
a pitch it's going to be terribly off so
maybe these people are just all
f'ed up confused messed up terrified and
so they're acting dude weird and it's
not that they're stupid when we when we
went over philip defranco's tweet you
know phil defranco yeah he tweeted just
like this really vile nasty thing like f
you you just like i'm not going to
apologize to you anti-vaxxer i'm like
when did people go it's like when did
they become evil yeah where they were
like i will burn you to the ground for
no reason well i think that the the
pressure that we've seen over the last
two years the pressure cooker that we've
all been in starting with the elections
we had the you know the january 6th
event we've had the covid lockdowns that
seem to be going on and on and on or at
least you know the regulations and um
you know we have the critical race
theory and all these things is sort of
uh you know a menagerie of forces or
people being pulled in different
directions by information that we're all
exposed to we're an information overload
sure sure but i'm just saying like
i mean why did people turn into
it it's almost like you know bilbo
baggins and lord of the rings when he's
all like oh frodo can i see the ring
you know like what happened to people
where all of a sudden they become
demonic and possessed oh but i don't
want to drag on we'll we'll get to all
this stuff for sure we got lydia press
and button i'm in the corner pressing
buttons i'm excited for tonight's
conversation as always very intrigued to
learn about mayo gate mayo gate man this
one got me really angry i it's and it's
it gets me really angry because
these are just regular working-class
people who don't care for politics want
to be left alone but i i've been saying
this for some time you think ducking
your head and getting out getting out of
the way no no they'll come knocking
they're going door-to-door i said this
was going to happen i had all these
leftists being like tim poole's lost his
mind saying they're going to come for
you regular guy did nothing wrong
they're they're coming after him they're
giving him bad reviews
it's crazy stuff man okay but we'll get
into it before we get started my friends
head over to surfinginternetsafe.com
to get access to virtual shield the
virtual private network service they are
the sponsor for tonight they say you
will stay safe with 50
off for life just 2.50 per month now
what is a vpn a virtual private network
help helps keep you safe while you're
browsing the web it basically routes
your data through a different server so
that's harder to spy on you and you've
got corporations hackers you've got
governments and they're all trying to do
it now to be fair there's different
levels of sophistication you know if
somebody wants to come at you they'll
probably find a way but
you got to have that basic level of
security to make sure that you know
hackers or whatever are not going to be
able to steal your stuff your data but
more importantly big tech companies and
websites are constantly trying to track
you this is one way to just
shut your blind say don't look into my
house leave me alone the way i always
describe it we don't expect anybody to
break into our house we still put locks
on our doors and windows because it's a
deterrent right so go to surfing surfing
internetsafe.com virtual shield the
virtual private network service they say
you can enjoy 24 months of online
security for the world from the world's
easiest and fastest vpn it's only 59.88
plus get 50 off all add-ons and and
other great discounts from their other
plans they're proud to announce that
this month all discounts are guaranteed
for life that means 50 50 off for as
long as you're our customer
this uh virtual shield my first sponsor
sponsoring us to this day after several
years i'm eternally grateful that
they've been here to help the show
continue doing its thing so if you guys
want to support them for supporting us
and you need vpn check out virtual
shield and don't forget to go to
timcast.com
become a member to get an advertisement
free experience from the website and all
of our awesome news we just put up an
exclusive report from the border from
your favorite journalist ivory hecker
she's the one who came out blew the
whistle on her uh her news station and
she just did a report from the border so
we we're running that you can check that
out we also have members only segments
so there will be a member segment from
this show coming up around 11 or so pm
so go to timcast.com and don't forget to
like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
because this one has got me more heated
than many other stories i've ever seen
my friends welcome to mayonnaisegate
we'll give it the funniest name we can
mayo gate
this is a story from wxii
winston-salem restaurants struggling due
to inflation caused by pandemic experts
blame inflated prices on high demand due
to the pandemic
high demand and low supply why is there
a low supply because in april four
million people quit their job they're
calling it the great resignation why are
people quitting their jobs because they
don't have to pay rent and because they
are getting 16 an hour on average from
unemployment payments that's not
literally every single person who quit
their job doing it for that reason but a
large reason is this when people don't
need to work to get money and they don't
need to pay rent they say to themselves
maybe i should do something else and be
more fulfilled i can respect not wanting
to work crappy jobs
but when people don't work they don't
make stuff when there's no stuff there's
low supply and the demand raised remains
the same prices will start going up now
many of these media organizations are
trying to obfuscate this they don't want
people to realize it is the fault of
democrat policies and joe biden's
administration so they'll do everything
in their power to lie cheat and steal
and the worst thing about it is this
story really grinds my gears because
they're they're attacking for no good
reason a local restaurant in north
carolina that didn't even get political
this is mayonnaise gate how hilarious
and sad here's what happened
they say
wxii spoke with the owner of the
sherwood a family-owned restaurant in
winston-salem pete straits
the owner to find out how much trouble
inflation has caused he says that an
increase in prices has put his business
in a difficult situation quote you can
only offset so much in this business and
it seems like every year you lose here
you lose there i'll give you an example
i'm paying 200 more a week in mayonnaise
now when i saw this story it was because
a bunch of democrat aligned media
figures
were mocking the restaurant and calling
them liars saying if prices went up by
5.4 percent that would mean that two
hundred dollars would that would equal
three thousand seven hundred thousand
mayonnaise per per week
because these people seem to think that
the price increase is static across all
products because they have no idea how
the economy works surprise surprise when
they try and push communism or socialism
what really happened because i called
the restaurant and asked them to clarify
on this uh one of the partners simply
said oh yeah you know we we do about uh
10 buckets per week they're five gallons
each and they used to be about 18 now
they're 36 so you do the math it's you
know 18 bucks and times 10 it's it's
about 200 and i went makes sense to me
and he said we use the mayonnaise for
our dressings and things like that and
anybody who knows who's worked in the
restaurant industry knows you go through
a lot of of
ingredients
like
well all of these here's what we end up
getting
we have this from indy 100 republicans
tried to attack joe biden over the price
of mayonnaise and the responses were
hilarious
they're saying things like here look
posting on twitter the official branch
of the party shared a story in which
restaurateurs expressed dis mayo about
the price of mayo what
yes saying there were they were spending
more than two hundred dollars a week on
it and claimed this was due to bite
inflation the restaurant never said that
that's a lie the restaurant never blamed
joe biden for this but indy is cl is
saying restaurateurs blamed by inflate
by inflation the north carolina
republicans must have been too hangry
and lacking in egg nutrients to notice
however the article they shared
they shared quoted experts who blame the
coronavirus pandemic on inflation and
not on biden here's here's what we have
from uh from the independent this from a
different writer gop ridiculed for
bizarre biden mayonnaise smear something
might be happening with mayo consumption
in north carolina these people didn't
bother doing a simple google search
calling a restaurant getting a quote and
saying how much mayonnaise is normal for
a restaurant to use we also have the
huffington post
republicans attempt to smear biden over
mayonnaise gets creamed on twitter how
much mayo can one restaurant use in a
week anyway and you get all your your
normal culprits aaron rupar everybody
knows aaron rupa yeah there's a verb
it's called rupar to rupar someone
what's the definition to take something
out of context and mischaracterize to
falsely frame a story what designer drug
is mayonnaise code for
jonah blank says somebody's eating way
too much mayonnaise then i don't i don't
care for these regular you know this guy
who works at facebook said just imagine
the heroic amounts of mayo this
restaurant must be going through
these people are a combination of
ignorant
arrogant and aggressive and that that is
is shockingly terrifying because what
does that mean they're too stupid to
understand how basic economics works why
a restaurant might need 50 gallons of
mayonnaise per week which probably does
the restaurant capacity i also reached
out 250 people
you get 250 people at one time in a
restaurant during a waitlist period and
you've all seen a weight you've all had
a weightless at a restaurant how much
mayonnaise you think they're going to
use for 250 people in a 30 minute period
and now how many people are coming to
the restaurant every day could be a
thousand
yeah
instead here's what ends up happening
they all end up lying saying mayo
flation
mocking the restaurant and it turns into
something much more terrifying when
people start going to their yelp and
saying things like one star review way
too much mayonnaise just mayo everywhere
or one star review too much mayonnaise
used to love the place but mayo is too
much and so i'm told
by the the the owner
at first they were like oh this is silly
what's going on this is we're getting
trolled or something and then he said
that this morning you know it got so
intense he starts getting scared he's
all these reviews are coming in you know
it's something something is happening
and he's scared about what's going to
happen
they're trying to make it seem like this
guy a regular guy who's not involved in
politics insulted joe biden and lied
about his the prices to make him look
bad and now these lunatics are actually
trying to cause damage to this
restaurant who is not political i have
said it before and i will say it again
if you think sitting down and hiding is
going to get you out of whatever is
going on you are wrong and all that's
going to happen is this will be th this
will be life for everyone you'll be
sitting in your your little cafe and
you're like i just run a small business
i have nothing to do with politics and i
don't want to be involved and then one
day antifa will show up and throw a
brick through your window because
someone accused you of being racist
we've seen stuff like that happen in
berkeley the people have to put signs in
all their windows i was in i was in i
was in berkeley for uh some protest
event and there was a nail salon with
you know all of this leftist signage in
the windows and i'm like there's there's
no way
these working-class women who are in
there
immigrants are that adamant about their
activism and so i went to a bar
and as i'm sitting at the bar i'm eating
a burger there was a big thing on the
window that insulted trump and said that
he was some kind of turd or something
and i asked the bartender i was like all
right what's you know everybody has
these signs in the window you know yours
is like you know more insult more more
derogatory and she's like yeah you know
you have to do it and i was like so you
don't do you agree with that message
like are you guys like anti-trump and
she said no
if you don't do it they'll smash your
windows
that's what it's like living in in the
bay area there was a burger king i saw
this was this was back in i think 20
2015 or 2016. a burger king had a big
sign in the window and it said please do
not destroy our windows we are a
family-owned restaurant franchise not a
corporate location
that's what life is like when you let
these people keep doing this stuff
during the the i think it was the was it
the g20 or was it the g7 i don't know it
was in hamburg they went around smashing
up storefronts and there's this photo of
all of these stores smashed up except
for one and do you know why that one
store wasn't smashed up it had the
communist fist in the window
this is an attack on a regular regular
regular family guy
this is the stuff that i've been saying
they will keep doing
and they and people want to act like
i guess
out of the 300 or so you know 320
million people in this country
excluding the children so you got maybe
250 people how many of them you know uh
are adults
yeah maybe maybe you'll you'll you'll
you'll be safe you'll be lucky maybe as
you know you're in the crowd and the
bear starts charging in you're like i
can run faster than everybody else maybe
you'll be the one person but man you
could stand up right now and tell these
people to shut up
call out the media for lying and going
after regular people who are not
political punching down as hard as they
can
or you can sit back and let your
children inherit this future
so i tweeted about this the other day i
said um
i said something about winston churchill
and his quote about feeding the
alligator and i said at this point
conservatism has become nothing but
feeding the alligator because all we're
doing is saying i just want to be left
alone just let me do my own thing i just
want to grill right that's like the meme
you can't do that anymore like you don't
have a choice and i also tweeted
something inflammatory about how it is
now your role to fight you don't get to
have your white picket fence you don't
get to necessarily have your american
dream because um it's being thwarted by
the far left and this crazy people in
the media and your role right now is to
figure out what you're going to do about
it and i think until people figure that
out we're going to have a serious
problem we can't just keep sitting back
and taking it but that's what
conservatives do
why
yeah well this story is more disgusting
than a mayo sandwich let me just put it
that way i'm marinating in it and i'm
listening to tim but what really jumps
out to me is that the democrats a long
time ago lost any pretense that they
care about the little man they are not
up for the real victims in society
they're the victimizers in the society
they obfuscate that by with their
grievance politics their identitarian
politics that they continually shuffle
out but they don't care about the folks
getting shot in chicago
anything that goes against their agenda
against their narrative they either
ignore it downplay it or attack people
who draw attention to it and this poor
guy in north carolina who's just trying
to put food on his family's table is
just trying to run a small businessman
is extremely difficult due to a lot of
the policies and democrat run states the
lockdown policies where are them
championing the little guys the small
business owners jeff bezos and amazon
raking it in hand over fist this entire
time they don't scrutinize how it's
benefiting corporations and
multi-billionaires
they don't draw attention to it they
forget they're the forgotten man this
guy in north carolina he's the forgotten
man in society he's just one example of
countless that you can draw attention to
of just grabbing what looks to be a
ludicrous headline
and their lack of compassion for in lack
of sympathy for this small business
owners who's obviously struggling is
illustrated by the fact that they're not
sympathetic with him he's like oh it
must be very difficult not only is it
democrat policies and joe biden's
administration that are responsible for
the inflation but the people who voted
him are gloating and mocking you and
laughing as you struggle through the
muck they're the ones who throw the
sewage on the floor and they're laughing
as you slip in it now let me explain
because it may be a lot of people saying
it's not it was inflation not joe biden
extended unemployment benefits people
are getting 16 bucks an hour not to work
we've already heard from many experts
that this is a a
push factor and so a lot of people don't
want jobs and the response we get from
many of the democrat establishment
activists is yeah well people shouldn't
work these crappy jobs anyway and they
should pay better so it's an
acknowledgement we know so long as you
give people the benefits if they don't
have to work they won't you've got the
the eviction moratorium people aren't
paying rent some people are a lot of
people are paying rent but some people
aren't this means that there is now a
bottleneck where retirees and
and pop landlords people who own one
building and rent out their basement
can't make ends meet this ripples across
the board
you've also got just
you've got the gas shortage caused by a
worker shortage caused by those factors
which causes all prices to go up so
inflation across the board is on the
rise so long as joe biden wants to enact
illegal eviction moratorium so long as
he wants to uh extend these benefits and
it's not just him it's the
administration the democrats and so long
as he wants to shut down a gas pipeline
which caused speculators to buy more i'm
not a fan of speculators by the way
causes them to buy more driving up
prices and then shut down fracking on
federal land which causes speculators to
predict short supply which increases
speculation and causes price to go for
gasoline these are factors caused by joe
biden directly his policies his
administration and democrats i am no fan
of the republican party i think they're
trash
most americans actually have a worse
view of republicans than democrats but
the democrats are the ones who are doing
this right now
so i tell you this
i feel bad for this restaurant
i'm also kind of frustrated with with
with with people like this these
restaurants
i can't expect him to have known what
was going on
but if you think that you can sit back
and ignore the world around you and then
you will be safe when the fires or the
storm comes i'm sorry that's just not
true all that is required for evil to
triumph is for good men to do nothing
and so you have i talked to the guy i
talked to two of the people at the
restaurant got a comment
and you know their sentiment was we
don't want to be involved in politics i
think both sides are bad both parties
suck and both sides are doing it and i
said i told him
the the right the anti-establishment
types these aren't the people who are
attacking your restaurant right now
because you expressed a fact about your
prices
so if these if regular people don't wake
up to these extremists by all means we
the alt-right they've been gone for
three years nobody likes them i get it
now we have a cult-like authoritarian
left that is going to attack anybody who
says a fact that goes against their
narrative or for no reason at all as we
saw with the black lives matter and
antifa riots all last year they attacked
other black small business owners
directly burned them to the ground uh
bashed their windows and i really liked
what you said about hanging signs uh in
your door just kind of as kind of a
totem or a sign when i when i go to this
lily white neighborhoods in westchester
county i see black lives matter sign
everywhere i don't think it's because
they sincerely believe in this
neo-marxist organization uh i think it's
a totem it's like a jewish passover
where you put the blood on your on your
door and you want people to leave you
alone i did a little social experiment
they had a church right next to a school
and they had all these black lives
matter signs and all of their little
punch phrases or your love is love etc
etc you know typical maoist type
brainwashing sort of things that they
put on the side i took a sign i ordered
it myself and i put i believe in racial
equality i believe in freedom of speech
i believe in and i listed all of these
different freedoms on there that i you
know just from the constitution and put
it out there you know basically to
provide some kind of contrast and i just
put it right in the middle of the signs
and just waited and i took a picture and
i came came back guess what they had
taken a sign and they got rid of it
because they are not for equality
they're for equity and that means the
government controlling all social
relations uh in this country and so no
you're not going to be safe
the the coveted passports all of the
stuff they are we're not used to this
sort of in-your-face intrusion but it's
going to get worse because as you can
see uh you know and nobody is safe it's
going to be like the social credit score
in china that you were talking oh yeah
yeah so so we got this story from k-ron
4
san francisco mandates proof of full
covet vaccine at indoor venues i love
this title indoor venues because it's
not the truth they actually explain in
the art in the article it's not indoor
venues what's a venue a venue is a forum
that's like a public forum where but
when you say venue you're thinking like
a bar or a theater or a concert you're
not thinking cafe
unless the cafe is a small stage i guess
but they actually go on to say that it
is it is more than just venues it's
restaurants cafes bars gyms
mayor london breed announced thursday
during a press conference
i i don't think the uh the vaccine
passport ultimately is the end is is
going to be the end result whether it's
intentional or not it's going to be that
you will have to show your papers
wherever you go it's funny that this is
literally showing your papers and we we
we have
a historical look at the fascists
regimes the nazis and why showing your
papers was frowned upon the idea that
you couldn't move about and freely
associate without some kind of id
and now you have what what's what's the
meme the the the the punch uh puncha
nazi people had a really quick 180 and
to show us your papers or something like
that
or or a glare an alarmingly an alarming
number of punch and nazi people are now
saying show us your papers this is it
and they'll start with something like
this but it's just about keeping people
safe with the vaccines
that's my issue with this that is all
based on a false premise
the cdc director rachel wielenski
admitted it
about
two weeks ago she admitted that the
vaccines so-called do not prevent
transmission of the delta variant for
example and right now we're seeing a
spike in the delta variant but the
mortality rates are low and the
hospitalizations are being
misrepresented but still it's so low the
specific issue there is they're saying
uh the vaccine will reduce your
likelihood to get it but the cdc also
says viral load in those with
breakthrough cases are the same as those
who are unvaccinated the bigger problem
i suppose is animal repositories yes of
course yeah
yeah right reservoirs we we've seen all
the stories about dogs and cats getting
covered and if that's the case and it
can transfer back i'm not sure
i'm not gonna pretend to be a doctor
because i don't know then that would be
alarming and i'm not you know we're not
vaccinating our pets so ultimately i'll
say this and i always do i don't give
medical advice i'm not here to
discourage or encourage anybody you talk
to a doctor make sure you do what's
right by you there was a story the other
day about this nurse in germany who
swapped out people's vaccines for saline
and that to me is a violation of
informed consent and psychotic if an
elderly person wants to get medication
their doctor recommends it
no one should be doing that that's crazy
but my bigger issue is hey men if you go
to your doctor your doctor says here's
the medicine i prescribe to you
i go to the doctor the doctor says okay
i shouldn't have to go to to get get
tested for something or then go to a
venue and show them my medical id
because it's going to go beyond that
this right now it's how they get you
they say well we want to stop the
pandemic you got to get the app you got
to get the excelsior pass and in a year
i tell you it's going to be something
else it's going to be oh did you oh you
said naughty words it's going to be
total social credit it was funny i
tweeted this i tweeted social credit
scores are next and some some like
establishment lefties are like you watch
too much tv i thought it was funny i was
like yeah you know i maybe because i
watched a documentary from the german
outlet dw and uh they interviewed some
chinese uh individuals working on the
social credit stuff talking about how
amazing it was and how crime has gone
down and it's it's so amazing now that
people are recognizing that you can't
just do these things like oh yeah
putting people in rigid boxes
the biggest problem i have with it
centralized authority doesn't work
it spins out spins out of control
dissent emerges rapidly and because of
the centralized control and and people
being pressed down there's no pressure
release for the people right there's no
protest there's no
leave there's there's no moment of of
being left alone and that's one of the
things i said a year or so two years ago
maybe i said they will never leave you
alone if you think keeping your head
down is going to keep you out of this
political conflict you are wrong
and the best thing you can do now is
speak up before it's too late
unfortunately
people don't care it's a sad it's a sad
tale man we have how many stories from
the past about totalitarians
authoritarians and why you must speak up
but i didn't speak up because i wasn't
ex or i wasn't why and i don't want i
don't want to lose my job because you
know i have kids
i said this over the past couple of
years speak up at your job when they do
the critical race applied principle
stuff speak up against it stand up
against it and people say but i'll get
fired
think about the future for your kids and
they say well you know okay well now
you're at the point where your job is
mandating uh either masks or vaccines
and we get people commenting being like
what do i do and i'm like you could have
stood up last year you know and pushed
back against the authoritarian you know
takeover but
for now i would just recommend first
going to your doctor and making your
decision on your own health and then if
you if you can't work at this place
whatever reason leave the job
yeah and i think what we're seeing right
now is that a bunch of the elitists who
are at the forefront pushing a lot of
these collectivist policies are not are
in a sort of cocoon of political
correctness they're taking the path of
least resistance they're not used to
people pushing back they're not used to
people and you don't even have to do to
push back in a sort of angry mean way
any kind of objection to them especially
if you show your human side and really
put pressure on them can be effective
and i've seen this firsthand when the
school just district that i live in they
did a critical race theory thing under
the guise of so-called unity day um i
you know the superintendent after i
shown a spotlight on it was like
effectively begging me to go and meet
them in person because they were
surprised at all the angry parents
responding so i went and i talked with
them and politely explained why parents
were so angry and gave them some options
and i think that you know
this kind of where you look at sort of
the middle managers uh in this system of
all of these groups that sort of are are
kind of at the front they're not used to
people being angry they're used to
social pressure that's basically how
they became a leftist to begin with is
because of peer pressure going with the
flow they need to understand that there
is no flow anymore there is no go there
is no
you know just go go along to get along
sort of thing where you can run in this
little suburban mom group and
everybody's going to agree with you you
have to make sure that you understand
they need to see you as a person you
need to look them in the eye and so that
you don't agree with them and you need
to
you know just show that show them that
that they're hurting people with these
policies and that they're causing real
damage to this country and their people
are suffering and that you know they may
believe they have good intentions but
nobody ever really explains to them the
the human cost like we saw with the with
the north carolina uh restaurant there's
a face to these people who they're
hurting there is a flow that people can
go with and it leads to a waterfall
yep so the people who are sitting back
being like hey man look i'm not going to
fight the current eventually they just
go well
well you could have turned around you
could have paddled against it you could
have grabbed a tree branch or done
something but people just said i don't i
don't want to rock the boat you know i
the captain seems to know what he's
doing and the cliff is right there
that's what it feels like to me
no one the people who are who are
running this stuff in in these town
councils and these city board meetings
they have no idea what they're doing
they have no idea what's going on they
don't know what is or isn't because the
rules keep changing and then you have
people sitting there being like well you
know they'll do it i guess
no you know people got to wake up and be
responsible for their own lives man
there's a there's a there's a
substantial substantive lack of personal
responsibility among a lot of americans
these days
yeah and i just i i think that right now
what we're seeing with this sort of
information landscape that we're all
we're all kind of immersed in and that
you know we're in independent media or
alternative media and they're trying to
change the landscape to take away uh our
opportunities to reach these people and
to organize them and you know i've been
trying to organize people to have
political pushback since the tea party
movement into 2010.
you know these sort of uh these sort of
organic grassroots sort of organization
that we need to do
um
that's re that's that can be successful
and it can work but you have to get out
and you have to you know make sure that
you're very visible i mean in new york
they recently had a protest against the
the coveted mandates and the uh in the
in the in the passports and they
and they made a real show to force but
it's just glaring how that's not really
the case in this country um it's kind of
um surprising to me it's kind of a
letdown that we're not really getting
out in force um so i just want to
encourage people to really start using
those networks that they built up over
the years and start you know
don't be afraid to go out and organize
and to do things the worst thing they
can do is is is try to force you to get
home and if you do or
force you to go home or dispersed for
not having an ordinance or having a
petition uh then
get it on video send it to influencers
make it known that there is real
authoritarianism behind these policies
and make them make people understand
that these are authoritarians they can't
hide behind i think there's going to be
a a big wake-up call for a lot of people
now with the mandates nbc news ran this
article saying that vaccine mandates
will hurt corporations that are trying
to hire because a lot of people are
going to be like wait what i have to do
what you know we talk about this
restaurant this guy is not political
doesn't know what's going on he's like i
don't want to be involved right
how many people were ignoring all of
this being like what we don't go outside
we wear a mask okay whatever
you had uh who was it bill burr the
comedian where he was like i turned the
tv every two weeks and then you know
they tell me to wear a mask i'll wear it
whatever you had ethan klein from h3
saying you just go to the cdc and they
tell you what to do you got to think
about it these are the people are going
to wake up one day when they go to work
and they're going to be like oh did you
get your your vaccine and they're going
to be like wait for my what
do you have to do that oh yeah otherwise
you're fired they're going to be like
hold on a minute because there's a big
line between wearing a mask and getting
something injected into you again you
know you go to your doctor the problem
is some people might have
okay and and i looked up the
pronunciation
uh
yeah and or you can you can if you say
it fast
syndrome all right and uh because it's
named after two guys that was their name
and because people keep telling me
different pronunciations for it so i
finally like just watched a video
talking about the scientist and i'm like
anyway
uh if you have if you have an underlying
health condition and your doctor
recommends against it people are going
to wake up hard to like wait a minute
hold on a minute there was this this
band playing a show in florida where
they said it's a thousand dollars a
ticket
but it's only eighteen dollars if you
can prove you've been vaccinated and so
this one woman gave an interview where
she was like my doctor recommended it
against the vaccine and now i can't go
to the show but rich people can
that's going to be the thing that kind
of pulls people into what's going on
like all of a sudden now you've got
people who are going to go to shop to
work one day and they're going to be
like you can't come back until you go to
your doctor and talk to them they're
going to be like really
and now people are going to be forced to
ask questions and engage well i saw i
saw just this week there was an ohio
judge that sent a man who had possession
of fentanyl and he was up in in front of
the judge and he violated his probation
in one of the terms of the probation
that he was be would be forced to take
the vaccine uh and one of the things
that was interesting uh about that is
the judge admitted i'm not a doctor and
he supposedly just referred to the cdc's
order and he had to wear a mask and all
of this stuff the cdc is de facto acting
as some extra legal actor in in our uh
you know in our
policy process but they are just
ultimately bureaucrats and not only can
they be wrong
they have been wrong
multiple times whether it's suffer
surface contaminants or viral load after
getting the vaccine and transformation
just goes on and on fauci recognizes
that you know he says the science
changed that the science doesn't change
your understanding of the science change
because you were not making it according
to the empirical evidence that is right
i think i think the the science changes
the problem is in an emergency situation
they're making recommendations off of
incomplete information so they're like
here's what we know so so fauci said
this this is actually what fauci said
that at first they said don't wear masks
then they found out asymptomatic people
were spreading it and said okay now wear
masks so they were still in the process
of trying to figure out what's going on
then they said it was aerosolized and
and instead of just and and so you know
and so a mask is not going to have any
effect it's short of an n95 potentially
that in a in a
setting i'll tell you the issue i have
with like with the with the
establishment with youtube on this one
is
celebrities can come out and tell you
go and do it
you can't come out and say don't right
right and the argument is well the cdc
is advising for these things right hold
on even okay so i i i i think i
shouldn't recommend anything at all i
think you should talk to a medical
professional you know somebody who
actually knows i don't want to get sued
if i give someone medical advice it's
bad i don't want to get sued if i give
financial advice that's bad i don't
think celebrities are in a place to
decide what someone should be doing with
with their with their health because
they may have like pete pirata formerly
of the offspring gilan barey syndrome
probably however johnson and so anyway
what ends up happening is you see all
these celebrities telling people to do
something
i think because of that blind zealotry
vaccine zealotry you'll end up with more
reports in the vera system people who
are adversely impacted because they
should have gone to a doctor and then
said to them like oh i have this that or
otherwise the doctor might have been
like oh okay for that reason i say no so
there's probably a small percentage of
people i do think the vaccines are
overwhelmingly safe i think it's fine
but i ultimately think
i'm not going to i'm not going to tell
an individual to ignore their doctor
like a celebrity would that to me is a
problem
if you want to tell someone to go to
their i even i even had uh establishment
democrat types attacking me as anti-vaxx
for saying
please go to your doctor i was on
twitter and i was like celebrities
should not be encouraging people they
should be encouraging them to go to
their doctor and people were like you're
an anti-vaxxer i'm like what
i really liked what dr drew said the
other day and this sort of a you know
mini viral rant that he had about this
that that when he was a doctor and he
was treating his patients the cdc was
like some kind of footnote that you know
okay
oh the cdc says that the wh says that's
great it's like goes in the file of
things then you just don't pay attention
to it very much unless it's a headliner
sort of thing of you know a drug problem
or something like this it wasn't
the authority
body that you took orders from
uh no if you have your license to
practice medicine you treat people on an
individual patient basis and you know
all the statistics you know the health
factors the risk factors you and you
know i mean you don't need the cdc to
tell you these things you need them to
publish them uh and sure sure there
might be some guidance there but it's
kind of like in the helpful suggestions
thing and a doctor can we go thank you
thank you very much for your opinion but
that's fine i've got it it's the
authoritarian creep right it was trump
trump's a hypochondriac and he gave full
power to the cdc and and fauci just
completely elevated it all and it was
like it's a horrible global pandemic
and then gave it up trump definitely
deserves some criticism for what you're
saying he has a germaphobe by here oh
yeah absolutely the handshakes for a
long time he did and that's why you want
to shake people here
i was told that he only eats fast food
because it's uh you can walk in
order it and it's already pre-made and
there's a there's a concern about if he
orders it to order someone will do
something to it well no wonder he he got
used to the ketchup that he puts on a
steak i think that may be the only
exception but did you you could be right
well i love the ketchup and steak story
do you remember this one do you guys
remember this one it's really really
good and i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
bring it back back up because we haven't
said it in a long time
there was a big report about trump
having this very fancy like dry age
steak well done with ketchup
and the media insulted him and ridiculed
him and said he was so uncouth and oh he
doesn't even have to eat steak oh this
guy's ridiculous
meanwhile
working-class union guy in the midwest
was sitting there eating his well-done
t-bone with ketchup going
that's how i like my steak
see when i was growing up we had the
garbage steaks from the from the local
supermarket you don't cook those rare
you got to cook them through because
they're not good steaks and then you
schlep ketchup on them so you do my dad
would always be like you know that's an
insult right it's like i make my steaks
good but we had we had good steaks and i
was kidding we weren't always eating bad
steaks but when we would it's like you
cook it through
donald trump does that it's relatable to
working class people who can't afford
the filet mignon to the rich people
they're laughing medium rare a little
garlic and salt what's he doing what
what a nut
just shows you how the establishment
hates the little guy like the story we
we we were leading off with but let me
let's talk about the story you see this
uh you see the protests breaking out in
tennessee over the over the masks and
schools
all these parents showed up yeah i saw a
clip of it this morning they're
screaming you're you know there's a
special place in hell for you we know
where you we we we'll find you we know
where you live wow you know what's
really crazy about this stuff first i'll
say a couple things we have the story
from cnn
school mass debate in tennessee grows
heated as local board requires masks in
elementary schools what's interesting is
that steve bannon told us this he said
come august 15th when parents see what
these schools are doing to their kids
the moms are going to come out and all
hell will break loose something that
affects paraphrasing
and it wasn't just critical race applied
principles it wasn't just the masses all
of these things and now it's august 12th
and we're seeing parents screaming at
these people
so i think steve was right about that i
think it'll be interesting to see what
happens in in the next couple of weeks
with schools coming back in full swing
and parents being like nah none of this
but the crazy thing about it is
these school boards
that are voting to have mask mandates
while there are 100 or so parents
outside screaming insults and and you
know we know where you failed threats
why are they voting in favor of that
yeah i don't know these parents will
have a long memory too they are not
going to let this go if they
do something to harm their kids mental
health like we saw that last year uh
with the mass mandates and and just the
policies that they put in place in these
schools depression went way up anxiety
went up suicide hotline calls went way
up suicide rates have crept up um they
they are
harming their kids to a lot of in a lot
of parents opinions not all some people
think that it's protecting their kids
which is why we cannot have a shared
reality right now apparently uh
so
they're not they're not gonna let this
go tim you know what you know you know
what these people don't understand
and i uh
so i'm 35
right
the day time moves much more quickly as
you get older they say and it's mostly
because things become routine at least
this is my view of it
when i wake up and have breakfast and
same breakfast over and over again i
don't have a strong memory of the
breakfast i had because it's the same
breakfast i had 100 times i'm older a
lot of my experiences are routine and
forgettable but the first time you wrote
a train i remember the first time i
would train i remember the first time i
flew in a plane because those were like
things in my life i'd never done before
when you're younger you're 10 years old
a day is a lot longer percentage-wise of
your life
so imagine
a year of not being able to go outside
go to the park go play with your friends
it's like putting these kids in solitary
confinement
i know a guy and his son committed
suicide
he was 12 because of the lockdown and
then his dad came out and started doing
advocacy saying like we can't do this to
our kids man you're an adult maybe you
don't mind sitting in your lounge chair
and relaxing and working from home but
these kids are trying to to experience
life
and it's being stripped away from them
if you're 10
10 of your life was in solitary
basically
ten percent
for me
one
thirty-fifth of my life was spent with
the lockdown and i'm i'm older and i'm
working running a company i've had the
experience i've traveled the world i've
hung out with my friends i've gone
skateboarding and now i'm like working
from home building a business
these kids they want to go out they want
to explore well i think the narrative
needs to be switched on his head uh
these children have a right to their
childhood they have a right to see
smiling people they have a right to live
in a pleasant environment they have a
and we're talking about the formative
years so it is really beyond a doubt and
you know i was a psych department
assistant i i listen you know i'm
immersed in all of psychology and
childhood development and so forth
you are stunning their psychosocial
development
it's really not even debatable it's it's
just a fact if you take away the right
to read you know the ability of children
to read emotions or to feel comfort and
to see smiling faces and reassurance
that you're basically it's kind of like
the that old video the wall from pink
floyd you know you're just creating like
this factory of faceless uh you know uh
and anonymous just sort of uh you know
you're dehumanizing them you're
alienating them you're atomizing them
and this for me it's it strikes me as a
political program it's not it's the
children are not in from what i've seen
the research wall street journal you can
go uh
just look at it they're not appreciably
at risk for this thank god it's one of
the small miracles that we can point to
during this pandemic and we're not
taking advantage of it it used to be in
society where adults were wanted to be
on the front lines they wanted to bear
the brunt of things they wanted to
protect their children um at all costs
and now we're seeing from what i
perceive as a lot of anxiety and
hysteria and selfishness on the point of
parents who just refuse to protect their
children
their childhood i mean
they
they're so selfish and narcissistic
they're projecting their own anxiety
onto their own child and for me that
just shows a lack of empathy and ability
to put yourself in another person's
shoes it's a real
social
scourge right now i posted
simply an image
from statista
of covid deaths by age group right i
said nothing made no comment screenshot
post
some establishment type democrat
activist
took the screen grab circled like
circled the elderly and then said tim
poole doesn't care that these people are
going to die and i'm like i literally
said nothing
i literally had no comment on the data
other than like i just posted the data
like here's some information for you
it shows you the weakness that they're
they're concerned about
the the largest group at risk are people
who are over 65 there is a decent risk
for people over 40 and the risk
diminishes for people who are under 40.
uh i believe it's like 1.63 of deaths
were under 40. close yeah and uh 30
according to the cdc of people
hospitalized were obese so it's much
more than that i read when it was 78
that cdc said they had obesity but that
is one study it probably varies it
probably varies cdc website is just a
headline yeah
30.2 percent of hospitalizations over
the past uh since the start of pandemic
was was obesity 94 comorbidities so i
think understanding all the context
having that information when you go to
your doctor and talk to them about what
makes sense for you and being healthy
take care of yourself eat right be right
be well all that good stuff ninety-four
percent of the people hospitalized by
governor had had co-morbid that's right
cdc says that yeah right so in other
words 1.6 average of people with
cardiopulmonary diseases lung disease uh
diabetes etc
morbidity yeah and so it's older people
yeah so there are plausible causes of
death and they happen to test positive
for covid as well
so they're not trying to do a diagnosis
of the cause of death necessarily but
they're saying
i will i will stress too a lot of people
think that the 94 comorbidity means they
didn't die from kovid but the way right
the way to describe it is like imagine
you have a bridge that's been old and
dilapidated and then someone jumps up
and down on it like the covet is jumping
up and down like well yeah if you didn't
do that the bridge probably would have
been fine so you get you get something
like covet and look we've had a lot of
people on this show
uh conservatives who have either been
vaccinated or have gotten covet and it
it sounds bad
yeah i i i
i've we've talked to some people on the
show i don't want to out the people who
have you know experienced bad sicknesses
but we've had people who are like dude
it was miserable
like two weeks of fatigue yeah you get
that with the shots too though i mean i
had the modern around a couple of those
and uh yeah it wiped me for a couple of
weeks so but but the thing for this that
we want to do we want to introduce it to
all of our troops for me that is too
risky these these are young athletic
you know physically fit people who are
not necessarily at risk that much uh
it's it's very similar to seasonal flu
if you look at the statistics for that
particular age group 20 to 30. and i
think it's very i think you wait until
all yeah but there's results come in to
make that decision so i think they
should be very careful about that
i definitely agree with being careful i
definitely think
the challenge here is i i hope that they
go on an individual basis that's always
the important thing because of potential
underlying conditions
but at the same time
i mean if we've got people that have to
go into conflict and deploy and go in
areas it would be nightmarish if there
was an outbreak of covid of of of any
illness really my understanding was that
you know people when they go through
basic they get a bunch of vaccines
absolutely yeah so i agree i think we
got to be really careful right now
simply because uh we need fda approval
for sure we need to make sure we're
doing right by all of the science and
without with even fauci saying the
science changes as we learn more it's
like okay well like let's make sure if
it's our military we're going to be
extra careful to make sure that we have
the capability to defend ourselves and
our allies and you know just
i'm just wondering if the vaccine could
harm
even metabolism or you know to have some
sort of lingering effects it is possible
that it could cause some sort of um
reaction and i mean because you're
intentionally stimulating the immune
system to have a response against an
antigen but that's anything that's
tricky that is true but uh this is
something that charlie kirk brought up
when we were on the debate with vosh he
mentioned gilan barai syndrome and he
said that the the you know uh cdc has
put out a nerve damage warning for the
johnson johnson vaccine
that that side effect actually is for
many other vaccines as well
so
you know i went to the cdc a few years
ago uh this was during i think zika and
i did an interview
because we were you know we were just
trying to find some like interesting
stories and it was around the time the
division came out you ever played that
game i didn't play the division awesome
game by the way and it's basically like
the world it's a post-pandemic
apocalyptic scenario and so i was like
let's go do an interview with the cdc
and ask them about their um i forgot it
was called it was like operation
something where they simulated a
large-scale pandemic and it was really
interesting and what i was told there by
some of the people at the cdc was
there are risks for vaccines and side
effects they're they're well known
they're on the cdc's website make sure
you read that stuff and talk to your
doctor because you could be in that that
small percentage group they said the
challenges were for a lot of these
diseases if there's like
we're expecting to get 200 000 deaths
from a disease and the vaccine could
result in 50 000 adverse reactions
we we have to choose the least amount of
damage so we'll encourage people to get
the vaccines and i i understand that it
is quite utilitarian but
i can't pretend to have the answers for
people other than but you see that with
children the mortality rate is f is
lower than the incidence rate of re of
uh reaction reported by varus but i mean
obviously mortality is worst case
outcome but pericarditis myocarditis is
and so on is very serious so i mean
obviously we see here we we second guess
and we arm chair a lot of these um
health experts but when you when you
look at
you know the the problem is and you see
with any kind of information system it
reminds me of a kind of like a hayek uh
versus kane sort of argument when you
have decentralized sort of um you know
decision makers uh you know uh we have
doctors who can assess individual health
risks and um and just have that
patient-centric care that we're so used
to in the united states uh where we have
a consumer model of of medicine
provision um
you know that is is has tended to serve
the united states people very well we
have lower we have we have superior
cancer treatment we have some of the
most advanced
medical centers in the world um
but what we're seeing right now is a
more socialized medicine approach where
bureaucrats who are not teaching are
treating everyone in american society as
if they're a homogenous group
and we're all likely to have a serious
reaction to covid when or the delta
variant which is predominant in the
united states right now and is much
weaker and less less deadly
statistically
it's treating us as if we're all at
equal risk this is not the way the
united states medicine has been
practiced uh and we've always relied on
our doctors to make the the best
judgments there's a few exceptions in
smallpox uh for example uh you know led
to you know mandates for vaccines so it
isn't the first time it's ever happened
in this country by the way um
but but what we see with the with the
vaccines is that it's rolled out so fast
with the warp speed and
you know there's a lot of conflicting
information we're in the information age
now and it's just we're getting pulled
in different directions it's undermining
trust for a lot of people and they're
projecting their fear of the vaccine uh
into their general distrust of the
establishment you know the people who
have problems with the election and the
people who have a problem with the
vaccine there's likely to be a very
large overlap however it isn't the
largest reticent group in the united
states demographically as african
americans followed by hispanics who
which asians seem to be the most likely
to go
you know what uh among educated the
largest uh phds phds yeah yeah it's
interesting strange i i ultimately think
there's i've been a lot of people
because i always say talk to your doctor
and then i get the typical response from
people is like doctor my doctor doesn't
know anything or otherwise and i'm like
you have a bad doctor you know what i
mean like uh
man i've been prescribed stuff in the
past i don't even know what it is you
know when you when i got like i injured
my knee they gave me some kind of
steroid you get for like
tendon inflammation and damage or
whatever i'm like i don't know what this
is thanks doc patch me up and send me on
my way doctor hands me a bunch of things
like here you go take this stuff uh i
don't know about prednisolone or
something
corticosteroids yes yeah so i i i had
damaged the uh
what's the what is it meniscus meniscus
meniscus knee yeah yeah i fell from like
a seven foot quarter pipe
what are you trying to do
i was just screwed i was chris and i i
was trying to do a rock and roll just
cruising around i hung up it happens you
know when the front wheels hit it and
then go to the doctor and he's like here
you go and he literally pulled out a
bunch of these little packets and he's
like you're good that's enough and he
was like he gave me the prescription he
gave me the regiment or whatever and i'm
like i don't know what it is i'm gonna
take it
if you don't trust your doctor you need
to find a doctor you trust and see if
the crazy thing about it is yeah people
can be political you might go to a
doctor and he's got like a biden flag
and he's waving in front of you then go
find a guy's got the trump flag and ask
him always a doctor i don't know find it
find a doctor you trust but yeah you're
right i think
this weird thing happened with it it's
very tribalist where there's a big
overlap between people who don't trust
the establishment and also are skeptical
of vaccines but it's isn't it
interesting how it switched with the
election
so this this is fascinating the the
polling data shows that democrats felt
the economy was bad
but right when joe biden got elected
they felt the economy was good like come
on of course we had nothing harrison and
other democrats were throwing shade on
the vaccine before the election and then
when joe biden's election no the
vaccine's fine everybody has to get it
it's a very weird it's a weird flip yeah
so i can understand you know people uh
here's the only thing i can understand
is i went and talked to my doctor my
doctor said ex like right on that's
that's all other than that
basing your view of your health off of
political tribalism i think is really a
bad idea like yo go for a walk man turn
twitter off and get away from this can
we rub that a little bit to the election
and sort of the controversy about the
election what we're talking saying with
the vaccine
right where we saw we saw people who you
know kamala harris telling people like
you know i wouldn't trust a vaccine from
trump et cetera you know i think you
know when we see the controversy in the
election of course we had mike lindell
cyber symposia all this stuff going on
it's still lingering the afternoon math
i've been people still distrust the
elections well the thing that i find
very interesting is and is that a lot of
the objections of people right now who
have problems with the 2020 election you
if you go back and look at nancy pelosi
you look at all the democrats and
running up to the 2020 election they
were
they were nervous that
about the voting machine companies they
were nervous about you know we had kill
chain with hbo yeah documentary yeah
harry hirsty and all that we you know
they were
you know throwing i mean you go back
early like 2020 you know on the house
floor they they were debating all of
these problems with uh with our
elections and um the lack of security in
the voting machines and so so forth and
you know the thing i find interesting is
that i would just you know one of the
things that i found just went viral
during this whole period of like in
november and december is i would just
find clips of
democrats or just tv shows talking about
how terrible our election security was
and
what really kind of opened my eyes is
when saisa came out said it was the most
secure election in history and i knew
that they could not have known that and
they just had no time to they had no
time to investigate so it looked like a
pr release so that really how did you
investigate the previous one that was a
big red flag for me he's like oh size is
saying it's already secure and they
could not have investigated it that
quickly and i'm not i'm not backing all
of the conspiracy theories and stuff
that flowed out there that proved to be
false like the german server thing that
was just a stupid rule now the china
hacking effect yeah all of that stuff
i've never i mean look i've looked into
it i mean if there was something smoking
gun there i definitely would bring it to
people's attention i'm i don't see the
smoking guns the closest thing that i've
seen to a smoking gun is just the fulton
county video with the
looks just like some shady activity
going there
the fulton
state farm arena they took people out it
looks like the election workers were
doing ballots multiple times it looks
that way but here that's the closest
thing to a smoking gun i was trying to
that's how i was trying to say i i see
those things and i'm like that's an
anomaly we should investigate but you
can't say what it is but it's just one
video they screwed up because it was the
state farm arena video they didn't know
that it was on surveillance and that was
subpoenaed there there were probably
there are multiple places that were shut
down at you know after hours and then
the you know that you had to have spikes
did they find those people actually did
scan balance multiple times see they
they
they they just found double counting
they never really went after them and
like kemp and raffensburg or whatever
never went after them i mean they
complained about it on social media
reference burgers like oh these these
people are neglig you know they they're
reckless in their duty and you know
we've had enough nobody was charged
right so i i think one of the issues is
with with an election involving what was
it like 170 million people or whatever
yeah you got 170 million people there's
going to be instances instances like
that right and you can't take one morsel
and extrapolate it into a large wide
spread you know claim or whatever true
but you're going down to like these
these swing states and for me like the
most substantial complaint about it was
that these uh
that the rules about the absentee
ballots and everything was changing
extra extraordinarily and extra
judiciously uh or
or extra legally let's put it that way
emergency powers were invoked in these
differences in georgia michigan uh
wisconsin uh and pennsylvania did not go
across the board yeah even even states
trump won the rules were changed yeah
there there were
there were executive orders issued in
some states others did pass it through
the legislature um but i'm just i'm
citing the ones that were brought forth
in the texas lawsuit that was just
dismissed not a hand for lack of
standing even though they gave an
indication that it wouldn't have held up
anyway um a hint that they were we're
not partial to it um
so i'm just saying a lot of these
lawsuits were dismissed on lack of
standing it wasn't really investigated
and that's really something that's been
you know driving me
is really to i wonder about the role of
private voting machine companies as this
sort of opaque intermediary where they
they own the source code in the
intellectual property they don't have to
give you the passwords uh
apparently as we see in arizona they
don't have to give them access so um if
they are tabulating our results who is
holding them accountable and how that's
that's the real issue it's very strange
it's very odd to me that that the left
doesn't seem to care about this
corporate for-profit entity sitting in
the middle of our democratic elections
with for with with pr
proprietary source right with
proprietary i mean there's people who
have suggested open source code
elections which could be a solution uh
don't get me wrong uh but i'm just
saying like these for-profit entities
and and like facebook funding these drop
boxes and majority blue
dem districts according to analyses um
this is a sort of unusual corporate
intrusion into our democratic uh process
that would normally be raising alarm
bells on the left and before trump lost
they were raising red flags and then
they just stopped because and and i
think you know right now i'm i'm in
favor of it i say do the investigation
do the audit let's see what they can
produce at the symposium fine whatever i
don't think so here's what i think the
real problem is that time magazine
article the shadow campaign to save the
election
it was the republicans in pennsylvania
drafting the legislation passing the
legislation for universal mail-in voting
things that changed the rules
dramatically what ends up happening now
is
the most fervent supporters of donald
trump who would be
the the the the the champions on the
front lines of fighting for voter
integrity are being distracted by
conjecture anomalies conspiracy things
that are very very difficult if not in
many ways impossible to prove
and if all that energy from mike lindell
was a voter integrity symposium and he
said and they went up on stage and said
in pennsylvania the constitution says
absentee bouts function this way and
they pass this that's not about that's
not that's about persuasion and that
would dramatically alter and and fortify
the system literally fortify the system
instead they're making claims that china
you know working with deep states and
nasa and then today you get this report
from the washington times not a leftist
publication by the way conservative
christian that one of the security guys
that mike lindell hired said the data he
had was a turd and he was tasked with
turning that turret into a diamond and
the the information does not
substantiate claims about china hacking
the election right and and what i'm
seeing on the right to kind of just
try to promote some healthy criticism on
that side uh of the of the conversations
what just what you said you should put
this energy into voter integrity laws
you should put it into trying to get
your legislature to hold voting machine
companies more accountable and to open
up transparency in those regards those
are responsible intelligent uh political
processes that we can work together and
possibly even persuade independence but
instead paranoia is stultifying it's
self-defeating it's debilitating but
some people are just
addicted to it they're they're they want
to grab on to paranoia because it feels
like their country is falling apart
their world view is being threatened in
the wake of history i think is falling
apart it they're yeah absolutely our
constitutional rights are definitely
being eroded on on almost a weekly basis
it's almost it's startling i mean we had
president biden with his eviction decree
violating the third amendment
amazingly you're very skilled some
somehow i didn't manage to violate the
third amendment amazing wow wow okay
congrats you get a you get in the
history book for that reason
that's incredible um but but just to go
to your point we definitely need to
really concentrate keep your eye on the
ball i'm not trying to take anything
away from mike lindell he believes in
what he's doing he's he's being sued
he's under fire by dominion he obviously
is a true believer in what he's doing
and and i give him credit for well it
seems to me that he's very fervent about
his cause he tried he tried to get the
lawsuit dismissed yeah i know and then
it said that the first amendment is not
a you know there's not an umbrella
protection for it he had initially said
that he was happy to hear he was being
sued because it would allow him to get
to discovery to pull the evidence faster
also it would have given him a venue to
prove with a judge overseeing it that
his evidence was true and correct if he
had the evidence to prove he why would
he get the suit dismissed he'd be like
oh great i've got to do i can now show
it to a judge and the judge is going to
be like wow he was telling me maybe the
dollar signs were daunting who knows
because it's like 1.3 billion dollars
it's in but it seems to be their
strategy truth is an affirmative defense
that's true and they're trying to scare
people right look if if i said the sky
is blue and someone sued me for
defamation i'd be like i will love to
come in and tell the judge look at the
sky like waste your money by all means i
don't got to do anything instead he said
he was very happy but then filed a
motion to dismiss which would obstruct
discovery at the very least he could
have had discovery that to me saying one
thing and doing another mean look the
guy makes great pillows i genuinely
think they're good pillows i got the
slippers i got the towels oh it's
because of jackpot to be honest like
he's like you know his tweets i'm just
like very personal i'm on twitter and
i'm like towels
we literally we didn't need towels we
need guest house and i'm like i see this
tweet one day and i'm like i was
supposed to get towels last week and i
didn't i bought them
but i just i i i put the code in right
you know what i'll throw stephen crowder
to steven crowder crowder said when he
was doing his investigative work that he
thinks someone gave lindell bad
information oh no and i wonder if what
happened was initially lindell was a
true believer
and then he started to be like wait a
minute maybe this isn't as sound as i
thought so i got to dismiss this lawsuit
and i don't know though i mean why would
he do the symposium i just look i think
you were you said it you know people
like the paranoia it gives them a
mission
i wish all of these people there was
like 190 000 people watching the
symposium or something like that imagine
if all of those people are watching a
symposium on voter integrity because you
look what's happening now in texas right
they pass all these emergency provisions
to make it ridiculously easy to vote
okay it should be easy to vote within
reason but not at the cost of security
you know you give up security you you
are you know you know you you weaken
your elections you can't get them back
instead uh
what's happening now is they served the
arrest warrants for the democrats
because they fled the state they're
saying we did it we passed the bill yay
the republicans are acting like they won
when they actually lost because their
bill is a compromise
the the reform bills we're seeing from
republicans don't completely reverse in
many states the pandemic provisions it
curtails them only a little bit we saw
this in georgia i think when they were
like this this voter suppression bill
and it was like it actually still
expands you could just put your yeah you
could just put your driver's license
number and send it in and that's new
yeah it wasn't that way before the
pandemic so the republicans are acting
like they're fighting back but they're
actually going like come in the back
door right and meanwhile the people who
should be standing up and screaming are
distracted because someone's waving hash
codes about china or something and it
and it's it's really odd and
if there is some mastermind presiding
over this i have to give him some credit
because the georgia
voter voter laws that you're talking
about are
weaker in some regards than like
delaware and rhode island and these
other blue states and yet when major
league baseball pulls their all-star
game out of the atlanta area everybody
in in you know the airlines issue these
statements everybody goes well
they assumed that it must have been a
really
legit
voter law that scared the left it like
it scared it scared the democrats and so
they had to do these extreme measures
right right and then they moved it to
colorado and then it's just kind of like
we assume on you know and the sort of uh
critics sort of the voter voter law
create the pandemic voter law critics
put it that way you sort of assume that
this is a good law and it has merit no
it's not necessarily the case there's
still a lot of loopholes going towards
let's say let's talk about freedom man
you see this thing with uh with arnold
yes
screw your freedom i shouldn't do that
impersonation uh arnold says uh screw
your freedom to vaccine hesitant
americans and uh that was it he was on
cnn for some reason with uh uh with
vindeman uh army lieutenant colonel
alexander for some reason the
whistleblower as he admits the the
general idea i guess from from mr arnold
uh the governator
is that with freedom comes
responsibility
and that in a pandemic people should be
responsible and recognize their you know
responsibility you know what he's not
wrong he's just a dick don't screw your
freedom freedom freedom is one of the
most important things protecting the
individual protects the system as a
whole decentralized systems work better
that's why america has been so bountiful
and successful and wealthy and that's
why the soviet union no longer exists so
no don't screw your freedom protect the
freedom and also recognize your
responsibilities but do it better in
this instance i think the issue is
we're facing one of the one of the one
of the most difficult challenges and
it's the threat of a pandemic from this
from the authorities to try and gain
i don't know
somewhat ancillary political powers
they're they're gaining so much by
exploiting this crisis
so the risk is
you know in during world war two we had
an office of censorship
loose lips sink ships that's crazy you
know we hate censorship but what would
you do during world war ii you never
know if someone's listening you might
have some information information wasn't
traveling as fast so we do recognize our
responsibility but i don't know i don't
know what are your thoughts on the
celebrity stuff well like i said uh to
arnold i don't think he fundamentally
understands what the issue is here is or
he's misrepresenting it it's not about
freedom you should always have the right
to decide what goes into your body um
whether whether a government authority
figure says so or not it's my body my
choice and and that goes back to the
point that i was suggesting is the
vaccine is ultimately works to prevent
you from getting severe symptoms of it
and doctor rachelle wendelenski drove
this out essentially a week and a half
ago so it's there in black and white for
anybody to go read what she said herself
but the point the point remains that it
is a decision to limit the risk of the
virus that it poses to me individually
and so it's it's each person's life to
live on their own and we should respect
each person's uh autonomy it's not like
people are going to be spreading the
disease if they're asymptomatic and they
haven't gotten the vaccine that that is
really such a far extreme outlier case
that we are really trying to put some
totalitarian system in place to prevent
extreme outliers it seems to be like
what we're doing did they did they flip
on asymptomatic spread
initially it's very low like it's it was
something like 19 to
30 percent of of the spread is pre
pre-symptomatic and then uh i think uh
asymptomatic was lower than that this is
this is why i can't stand the
celebrities this is one of the most
damaging things you could do if you were
actively trying to get people to to get
the vaccine the best thing you could do
to protect individuals to make sure we
reduce the amount of adverse events that
we see in fears and to is to tell people
i trust you to make the right decision i
trust you to talk to someone you trust
like you you've gotta you gotta give you
know what i mean when you come out and
you bash someone over the head
figuratively like do as i say or else
they say i don't trust you when you say
screw your freedom you're like you're
turning it into a political paradigm at
that point right what you need to be
doing is if if i was going to trust
somebody who took the vaccine and look i
decided to take the vaccine because i
crunched the data i said states that are
have higher vaccination rates that looks
like they have less
percentage of people who are getting
severe symptoms it seems like it's
working so that persuaded me like i just
did my own data analysis and ran the
comparative research and i found that
okay it holds up it it washes so you
look people in the eye and people who
are hesitant are afraid to use the
vaccine and i'm not telling anybody to
use it or not use it don't don't don't
get me wrong but i would say you appeal
to you like you know i don't want to see
people get extremely sick with this
virus i don't want to see your children
lose a loved one
over this and so if you're at risk you
should talk to your doctor about getting
this because it could really save your
life potentially if they would just
leave it with that kind of
a sincere pitch then it would be more
persuasive to people but when you
interject the politics in there and the
mandates and and where we already have
uh what's the fully vaccinated rate is
60 percent plus in the us yeah i think
it's over 60. i 50.2 60 of adults i
believe um
more or less yeah 60 of adults i believe
the last time i checked the data
australia was two years ago
yeah wow yeah and and so i i just
believe that um
you know it does help to for people for
adults who are especially over over 40
98.4 or so our of the mortality is is
over 40 years old um so i think that the
statistics bear out that you should get
it you should consider getting it at
that rate um
the issue is freedom but they're not
yeah but they turn into a freedom versus
authorities this is why the arnold thing
is such a problem yes because we're
talking about vaccine passports we're
talking about you know
uh libby evans who was on the show uh
recently she she tweeted that
she doesn't believe children should have
to wear masks but her child will be
wearing a mask because there's no
options in new york city and i'm just
like
leave new york city you know like
don't make your kid go if you think it's
wrong for your child you make the choice
it's about freedom so when he's saying
screw your freedom
i don't i don't feel like he's actually
talking about the the vaccine to be
honest i think he's talking about the
expansion of
the surveillance state the expansion of
people demanding you show your papers
things i do not agree with
i think
there's there's there's a there's a mix
between individual responsibility and
responsibility to the greater community
and we have to find a balance and it's
not in authoritarianism making everybody
adhere to a strict authority now people
have to have to have to have some level
of you know autonomy
that that's why i was saying like the
soviet union they lasted what 69 years
fell apart
the united states a couple hundred years
and the wealthiest most powerful country
and all that good stuff it's because of
decentralization it's because of liberty
right it's because people can challenge
the status quo we're losing that i think
there are times when you want to install
authoritarian you know activity to
preserve a nation which we did with the
polio vaccine i think or with smallpox
we brought up earlier
smallpox however does not exist in the
animal population other than humans that
we knew of so that was why we were able
to vaccinate and wipe it out so it was
an effective use of an authoritarian
vaccine
this virus seems to exist in the animal
population meaning that you can't
destroy it with a vaccine because it's
going to be all the animals that aren't
vaccinated at all times
mutations can occur in animals i guess
right and then the mutations are jumping
it seems more similar to a flu which is
difficult to you can't have we haven't
figured out how to you know eradicate
flu yet right so i don't see in a thor
it just doesn't make sense to to
authoritatively do that it'll be booster
shots forever i mean it's john that's
third third shot came out today
for the immuno compromise but but you
know what okay good all right so but the
issue should be on the policy front it
should be
uh get your yearly coveted shot
but not mandate not lock everything down
i don't i don't have an issue with
yearly flu shots it should be it should
be like the flu shot and what we're
seeing with the delta variant is sort of
the normal course of pandemics that
we've seen from 1968 and um
1919 um
we where you have this deadly wave and
then it gets the mutates into a more
contagious but less deadly
variance so it's very sort of a natural
flow of it that's kind of hidden with
the obsession about cases right now but
that but if you look at the mortality
rates and hospitalization uh legitimate
hospitalizations uh it kind of bears it
out um and what i mean by that is like
they don't go into a hospital for a
routine
checkup or something and they happen to
test for cova that didn't doesn't
necessarily mean they went there for
covid so
this very opaque data is is difficult
and they've made mistakes with it lately
but the point is that it does seem to
strike me the risk breakdown is like it
should be like a flu shot we the doctor
says i recommend that you get it because
you're obese or you have um some sort of
health factors and you're in the you're
in the age group um but mandating that
children get it i don't see the science
there
i just generally think the mandates in
general yeah like cause the problem
there you the problem arises when
like that that venue i mentioned where
the woman couldn't go to a show because
her doctor recommended against it are we
really going this route where it's like
you in new york city you're not gonna be
able to go to a bar because they're like
well then you gotta get negative tests
so we're gonna put a financial pressure
i i assume that i heard they're not
doing the free tests anymore i guess so
now what every three days you got to go
to a clinic because you have an
underlying medical condition it's like
it's like throw the ada out the window
man i i'm i'm not okay with that i think
we have to respect
individual autonomy and
well one thing that we could say right
now about the progressive left is they
haven't been hiding who they are for
since woodrow wilson uh they have you
know you you brought he brought up like
the alien sedition act it's or the alien
yeah the alien sedition act again part
two uh that basically made it against uh
against the government to criticize it
during wartime et cetera
they have wanted a tech
technocratic managed society since that
period and what the information aided in
1990 is giving them the tools to do it
and since everything is a means to an
end for these people and you could read
it in saul alinsky you know revelly for
radicals or whatever uh everything's a
means to an end so they will weaponize
the doj they will weaponize the cdc they
will weaponize every tool at their
disposal there is no moral
um
barrier that was in the place when the
constitution was written for them they
don't even see those barriers they see
the the utopian end line as a perfectly
little managed ant hill where they
basically just direct people to go in a
place and it's all harmonious and
everybody has their little food in their
little house and their little transport
and it's not polluting the environment
et cetera et cetera and that's what they
see and i you know that's where you get
like very intelligent people support
these sort of causes they don't see it
as authoritarian they just see it as
proper management of society um and so
for us you know or not i'm not going to
speak for you but i mean from my
personal perspective respecting the
constitution um in an individual rights
and wanting people to have their life
protected because they're given this
gift they have this agency they have
this
wonderful chance to
uh just
experience uh life with all the freedom
and opportunity and
control that they have over their own
lives this is if this is taken away
then humanity is as we know it is lost
it's not
for me humanity sort of ceases to exist
yeah it'll be the borg yeah you know you
know what you know what
you know this is it goes back to uh
colleges when i was a kid
and everyone kept demanding i go to
college you got to go to college get
that degree i was like i can't afford a
good college get loans why what am i
going to do in college you know i was
lucky
because i was told when i was in grade
school trust me grade school is stupid
once you go to high school it's so much
better they have these different
programs and you can choose some of your
classes and i was like oh okay
and then i went to high school and it
was the exact same trash and so i said
i'm out then when they came to me and
said college is different trust me i say
i'm not going to believe you this it was
different though no it wasn't you i know
you don't have to go to class i went to
i went through that
on that one yeah well sure i guess
truancy laws don't exist when you're
paying the bill but i went to a
community college for a couple months me
too and i was like this is a waste of my
time complete waste it's the same same
garbage here's here's what ends up
happening
you get these young people
they they haven't had jobs ever they're
22 years old 24 years old they've never
had a job and they're and they're
graduating college
they have massive debt they can't pay
off
they're now they're trying to enter a
labor market with no discernible skills
other than a college degree so they're
getting entry-level trash position
positions where they struggle to pay off
their college debt
and then they eventually say
someone paid this for me the government
should pay it for me it's not my fault
and where's the authority figure to tell
me what to do because throughout the the
entire lives in the institutionalized
institutionalized learning facilities
there was always an authority telling
them what to do and now here they are
once again saying someone should be
telling you what to do i shouldn't have
to deal with this or pay for it
instead i think people should get jobs
you know when they're younger real ones
but a lot of these kids didn't do it i
can't tell you how many people i know
left as activists told me their life
story was like you know i went to grade
school then high school then college and
i graduated college and here i am as an
activist i highly if you're a parent i
highly advise you to get make your kid
get a job when they're 12. just
something local lawn mowing well pay for
me i waited to go to college and i
worked for like five years doing menial
jobs and stuff that kind of sucked to be
honest with you uh you know it was tough
i was in southern iowa and i i i mean
basically i went to college as a way not
to go to work a sucky job because my
grandpa was like oh well you know i work
in office you got to go to college or
whatever so and i got that's not true
well and well i found that out because
when i got my four-year degree i mean i
triple majored and then you know
poli-sci russian stuff uh
you know i found that like i tried to
get a job right after four-year college
and it was like almost impossible there
was a flood of four-year graduates and i
was just like well i have to go to
graduate school then to really show that
i'm not a bser and then i know how to do
research and i know i know my stuff so
i'm going to have to go to a two-year
you know a great time as a bs or the
bachelor of science yes yes
i found that uh
you know in the past 10 years my
experience has been college degrees have
been detrimental in the hiring process
so one of the stories i've told is about
my friend who was running a mid-level it
was it was a small business but he did
like medium chain uh businesses
restaurants for digital marketing and he
kept hiring college grads because he
assumed the degree meant something they
couldn't do the work they constantly
called with problems and complaints like
hey the the client did this what do i do
and he's like i hired you to do the job
figured i'm not here to do a job for you
and then eventually
he fires him he hires more more people
they have same problem he fires them now
he's running out of money so he's like
he goes on craigslist and he finds a
couple of people who are like i moved to
la to be actors
and he was like i can only afford to pay
you you know x per hour and they were
like sounds good to us so we got him for
cheaper
never called him with a problem and so
he told me the story where he's like i
went out i was doing a meeting with new
clients and then
i don't get any i don't hear anything
from them i'm kind of worried because i
know there's always problems with
clients they're not calling me i go back
to the office anything happen today like
not all good boss no problems with
clients oh yeah one of the clients
posted something done but we took care
of it and then he said he realized the
kids who defied the establishment when
they said go to college and get a degree
when they said i'll do whatever you say
these are the people who couldn't solve
the problem on their own but the kids
who dropped out and said i'm gonna go on
i'm gonna go find my own path or the
people more likely to solve the problem
on their own
i so i i this is a story that i've heard
throughout my life and i'm fortunate
enough to have the internet and to have
friends and to really thought this
through to think this through i remember
reading about just doing the basic math
you're 18 years old you started a fast
food restaurant you work for four years
after four years you're probably making
a little bit more money you've probably
saved a little bit of money and you
might even be an assistant manager you
spend four years in college you're now
negative 40 grand you have no work
experience and you're hoping that these
businesses will hire you based on your
degree but you're probably going to get
a gr entry level position meanwhile your
buddy was the same age as you is a
manager making you know at the time you
know 30 or 40 000 a year and you're
making 10 bucks an hour
so i knew this one kid
he told me that he went to a web dev
firm because he was a web developer
self-taught he was he was a kid he was
just learning to
do you know do web dev stuff
he got hired
for i think i think they were paying him
like 27 000 a year this was 15 years ago
or whatever and he said what they told
him was everybody who came in with a
degree had high salary expectations
because they had to pay off their debt
and they said we don't have enough to
pay you 40.
and then so all of a sudden this kid
comes along was 18 and they're like do
you have the skills to do all these
different things he's like oh yeah and
he shows him his portfolio and they're
like perfect house 27 and he laughed
he's like 27.
whoa that's so much money
and he said his boss told him straight
up we couldn't afford to hire the
expectation these college grads wanted
so we thought we weren't going to be
able to hire anybody and grow the
business and then you came along we were
able to afford you because we didn't
have that premium on college degrees so
i always tell people
the most important thing right now
especially with the influence the
attention economy social media
influencers you got to learn yourself to
solve problems i think college is
quicksand it is it is it is they're
throwing you off misery loves company
hey i went to college you should go to
college too now you're finding out that
a lot of these these these businesses
say college degree or you know
equivalent experience
if you got a portfolio and it's really
really good they'll hire you
if you if you show up and you're like
you know i once interned at a company
and i have a degree they're going to be
like if you can't show me the work i
don't care
yeah so don't waste your time if this is
an actor i went to school for acting and
in the modern economy you're better off
making a youtube channel and getting 600
000 subscribers in the four years after
high school than going to acting school
if you want to become a famous actor
after that because they're going to hire
you if you have a million followers
they're going to put you in a commercial
you're going to get be making six
figures per job but if you go to college
then you give me 15 years that you're
like oh i got to start a social media
account when you're in your 30s and
you're like i've seen so many people
they're just now starting their ins like
just now starting their social media
presences my friends with actors in l.a
it's just sad yeah well i mean i started
i went to art school for a
couple of weeks i don't know a month and
i dropped out i was like whoa they want
to charge me 80 000 so some i mean if
i'm picasso it's going to be obvious to
people i don't need to be do uh still
life's you know to kind of build myself
up either i have a passion for it and i
can do it on my own or i can't um
that changed uh i mean i wound up going
to a community college because it was
much more cost effective but then i
found out i was good academics
psychology etc and so i kept pushing and
pushing but it's kind of it's kind of a
trap because you know if you if
you know i i tried to go to college to
sort of escape the the poverty and the
kind of realities of work a day life and
it was just such a contrast that i could
go to school and you know be be around
you know be around other young people
and just having fun and learning things
which i love to do but i just kept on
kept on felting like i had to keep going
to separate myself from others um my
first job was hired at a little liberal
arts college in bar there's a little f
there's a funny story about this um very
briefly i was hired as an international
program manager for about 37 thousand
dollars in new york which is not much
for that state um
scrap scrap by for about did some
interesting things for about six months
but then i was sort of let go because
she figured out i was not a raging
leftist this was a manager who is well
connected with george soros
and i was sort of the liaison between
this uh the bard college uh and uh saint
petersburg in russia smalling institute
or whatever and i would speak russian
and so i was kind of the liaison here um
it's funny that uh you know
putin sort of figured out that this
small liberal arts college was soros
funded and soros connected
and uh
basically had cut off all ties to them
so right when i when i when they when i
left this job at bard college years ago
i went to pursue my phd at suny albany
all of them marxist stated maoists
marxist leninists um you know a little
bit of fabian socialist thrown in but
not much
and i studied marxism but but really
the the whole process for me is a little
bit the only value i got out of it was
just realizing they're full of s
that was the only thing because i kept
going because i'm like god surely these
guys have 150 160 iqs they have to have
some knowledge and wisdom to impart with
me no that's not what they were doing
they were really just grooming people to
be a part of a
activist radical movement they weren't
really looking for truth they were
looking to change the world
in their own image in their own
perception and they wanted to recruit
foot soldiers into it and kind of you
know kind of regressing you know
progressing through the ranks so you can
make colonel oh you can make general you
know if you're a 10-year doctor or
whatever in this sort of you know
weaponized college environment so i when
i left i went to independent media
independent journal review um got in at
the ground floor one of the first few
people hired and it it just took off but
the value i got of it was just i know
their agenda on the inside like i had to
read stacks of
social science gobbledygook that would
just make you know a normal person you
know
mind melt because it's just like it's
really a brainwashing program and and so
when i talk to a superintendent at you
know a local school district or whatever
who has a phd or whatever
like you know at least
i can kind of understand what's behind
the superficial sort of crt program and
like you know oh
i mean it's kind of like you can't be
sobs or like i already know where you're
coming at with this i know what your
objectives are it's to make kids um
more woe could just did you see that
rumble announced there they like
basically signed a bunch of people to
produce content oh good i've been using
rumble for a while since youtube youtube
actually gave me a strike
the only strike i had on my account
was for showing donald trump at a public
appearance
i just posted the video of donald trump
talking no commentary no nothing
apparently he must have uh
mentioned the verboten election word you
know and that was it they gave me a
strike for that and then that's just
like woke me up so like i can't even
just objectively do any kind of
journalism or anything and they'll just
they'll say if they don't like it what's
fascinating is the criticism that
establishment journalists are throwing
at this eclectic group i mean you've got
suraj hashmi he's not a concert like
he's not a hardcore right-winger by any
means uh you've got uh tulsi gabbard
yeah i know you know uh she's rather
progressive actually uh and glenn
greenwald and it's funny when i see this
criticism
boy do they really hate
they're so jealous
they're working for skin suit companies
you know the new york times
it's it's it's got funding because it's
got name value it's long standing and
people subscribe to it because it's just
got that that position right
but uh we here at timcast.com go to the
website sign up we are not funded by any
millionaires or billionaires it is just
the users the members and the the
revenue we get there is no surreptitious
or uh funding or high profile investors
this freaks them out it's funny to me
that they're they have this attitude on
on twitter where they try to say things
they insult me for being a high school
dropout and stuff like that and i'm like
yo i'm proud of that and then they go it
shows i'm like it certainly does because
you guys don't understand the difference
between deontology and utilitarianism
and i'm just some dude who reads online
and you went to school for that stuff
i'd like to imagine having an economics
degree not knowing what capitalism is
can we call you alexandria a high school
opt out because you definitely didn't
drop in anything
i mean you you elevated when you left
that organization
yeah
it was dragging you down and you were
able to el you didn't drop out you you
raised up out of it it's funny because
uh you know they like to take things out
of context and then argue that i'm like
dumb or whatever and i'm like that's
fine by me i don't care what you call me
i'm like we're running we got here a
growing company we've got a couple dozen
employees at this point where we're i
think we'll probably be at like 50
within the next year or so just getting
bigger and bigger and bigger we're
talking about how we got to figure out
we're going to put the new headquarters
we've got to buy another building oh man
i'm so upset that these people don't
think i'm smart when they're not able to
find a job and they're struggling with
their lives and advocating for insane
policy that make no sense and we're over
here having a very successful business
so i'm not saying that because i'm
trying to drag them down or insult them
or i'm trying to justify you know
my my ego to myself or anything i'm
trying to point out don't let these
people lead you astray with their bad
advice
misery loves company they want you
sitting in the cesspool because crabs in
a barrel man they will pull you back in
you don't you can find your own way you
can be successful if you build it
yourself i think the path of success is
perseverance it doesn't matter if you go
to school it doesn't matter what country
you're from if you keep working you work
hard enough you can succeed no i'm on
the same page obviously i i
i figured that out i mean i i was at fox
news for a while until the election it
was a great experience in a lot of ways
insightful to be on the inside of a you
know a big cable news show
but since i left and went on my own you
know you can do it you can start your
own company it is possible still
for now i would knock on wood but i'm
not allowed to bang on them
uh and so like i mean i've had a great
experience i mean i've syndicated with
uh trending politics
which has been a good partner of mine um
and you know
my my works get read and i am really
grateful for that but i mean obviously
you know
now is the time to push like there's a
the twilight is shrinking uh so you know
there may be a couple of years left but
what you know i'm grateful to places
like rumble um that are at least giving
such a more
trustworthy outlet than youtube i'm not
a fan of your youtube and if i
do my own podcasting thing it will be
with rumbles youtube is an afterthought
for me and i'm glad i'm glad you know
google alphabet really
yeah yeah right right which i never
understood why google was able to buy
youtube but you know that's really
that's another conversation was it
online yeah one there's the first one
billion dollar acquisition it is yeah
it's for me it's wild but let's go to
super chats yeah if you haven't already
give us a like smash that like button do
it for ian do it do it for you hit it
and uh uh become a member at timcast.com
so you can check out the bonus segment
which will be coming up we we usually
post them around 11 or so pm because we
record them and then publish them they
are recorded live but they aren't live
themselves and uh share the show with
your friends if you like it let's read
some of these super chats
all right let's see
doc hollande says the ccp with with all
its authoritative power couldn't prevent
subsequent outbreaks how much power are
we prepared to give our government to
stop a pandemic that couldn't be stopped
by a totalitarian system that's a great
question yeah that's a really good point
actually i had a friend that had cancer
and she was taking medicine and
pharmaceuticals i was like why don't you
try diet and she's like nam the doctor
just told me to take this take this but
she was still feeling kind of ill i was
like are you how long are you going to
let them tell you what to do how long
are you just going to go along are you
going to let them cut your arm off and
that like shocked her up and she went no
and ever since she's had a way more
clear head on her shoulders about that i
think people need to realize that
medical professionals are people
just like plumbers or people and
carpenters are people and there's such
thing as the bottom of the class the
medical school so make sure you get a
good doctor man that's right because
they'll they'll we we are the experiment
i mean of the medical this the human
race is the yeah it's a giant ongoing
experiment that we're all part of i i
have i have had a lot of really great
doctors in my life who have advocated
for like good diet i've had doctors tell
me like cut the sugars out sugars are
bad meanwhile you get the food pyramid
which is garbage i've had i've had
doctors that i feel like have been
completely honest so i don't know
whatever you know but yeah i think that
the point i want to make sure we hit on
this one is
china welded people's doors shut and
they're still dealing with problems
right now they're locking down again so
it's just like like how far is too far
decide that right now for yourself and
remember that if it happens yeah right
all right harry toe says mayo is racist
end of story
all right
if you say so
grayson says ian check out a youtube
channel called voices of the past they
read old journals and first-hand
accounts of historical events for
example the japanese perspective of the
first portuguese traders oh that's
really interesting
the animal cracker says amc is still
going to the moon tim are you still a
diamond-handed space ape you guys should
look into having trey collins on he is
the spiritual leader of the apes i am
still diamond handed space ape i have a
bunch of amc i like amc i like movies uh
i don't i've not been following the amc
stuff and the short i'm not you know
look by all means people do your thing
whatever my attitude is we went and saw
what movie did we go see black widow i
love going to the movies man pretty sure
we went to an amc
so i like it i it's it's one of the
things that i'm really upset about when
they locked everything down i was like i
don't got to go to a restaurant i can
make fun i'm happy with that but the
movies are fun did you guys ever have
friends or work at a movie theater or
have friends that did yeah let you
upstairs and yeah
yes
well my uh my russian teacher in high
school he had a movie theater and my
buddy worked there and we went up there
and
really one of these small town movie
theaters and ain't nothing like it the
feel of it and
the musty smell of it
all right uh
twimmy says personally not a fan of this
new format i've been a fan since the
true show shim cast began this new tim
guy is a far-right anti-back beanie
grifter bring back shim cass down with
tim castle sheamus is a is really good
at what he does he is yeah oh yeah we're
uh tough to talk him we're launching a
non-profit all right uh journalistic
enterprise it's gonna be a fact-checking
uh outlet okay the the the way it'll
work is i've been talking about for a
while but we're actually filing the
paperwork now and sheamus will be
involved too so i'm really excited it is
uh
we're going to sample 100 articles
within like the past month from every
news outlet and then we're going to go
through the articles based on the the
standard journalistic ethics from like
the spj or whatever and then if there's
any violation we give the article an x
and then we load it up and we say out of
the hundred articles reviewed 63 were
rated as
you know ethical journalism you know 37
or whatever
outstanding i'll be sure to keep an eye
on that i think you'll see like the
huffington post get a zero and i'm not
i'm not telling it to be me and i'm
saying it's because they're clearly an
opinion website but they don't label
their articles as opinions well to write
up on that mayo article i mean it was
something like you would fail if i was a
professor at the community college you
would fail for just
right so many reasons so uh if they're
asserting something to be news but it's
opinion that's an ethical violation so i
do think there's a lot of conservative
commentary sites that will also get low
scores for that make sure to keep an eye
on reuters and ap because i feel like
they've been uh yeah reuters they've
really been hurting their credibility
lately and i used to respect them a lot
but i think the last few years trump
broke them i think for whatever reason
minimizing harm is a journalistic ethic
so cnn for instance when they
named the warehouse worker who posted
the meme
that was a violation of journalistic
ethics you don't need to destroy the
man's life to tell the story so they
maximize time in that regard we'd give
it a next what we're going to do is
we'll have a spreadsheet for each outlet
and we'll list all the articles you'll
see all the articles you'll see circles
and x's and then it'll explain why is it
possible to find how many violations per
article like if one article has six
violations and then they consistently
have six violations per article that's
like six times the violation that's way
worse than a company that does one
violation article no no it's it's not
about whether or not their articles are
egregiously bad it's about do like it's
a harder standard in this capacity are
they correct is it it's hard if they are
or they're not perfect or is it slightly
off it's slightly off it's a full access
full fail
and so a lot of these leftist
publications that is purport to be news
and if they're raided by news guard as a
new as a certified truth oh we're we're
going to come out and be like well we
will use news guard and we will use
wikipedia
specifically if so like having a post
for instance is considered by wikipedia
to be a reliable news source
whoa yes and newsguard considers them
reliable news source for that reason
they will get zeros across the board
because every article is an opinion
piece absolutely and they don't put
opinion on it and so and we'll say that
so long as establishment institutions
rate this source as reliable news and
the and the institution itself
considered itself to be a news outlet we
will not give them past as for the daily
wire they call themselves conservative
commentary and conservatives in the news
in that case we might just say this is
an opinion website we we don't rate
ethics and opinion every single one of
my articles has opinion on it because i
just feel like there are just so many
assumptions i'm i'm arguing against uh
most of the time i'm arguing with
counterfactuals and providing data and
evidence but it's very much framed in
the sense that
what the mainstream media understanding
of this subject is lacking you know so
here's here's some more information
about this narrative when we when we run
this if your website says this is uh on
opinion analysis website then it's then
we just say this is an opinion analysis
analysis website we don't we're not
we're not here to rate the new york
times for instance when they publish
news are they putting in are they
injecting so so look a lot of these act
a lot of these partisan sites will
probably be fine because they just say
they're you know leftist commentary or
activist commentary or conservative
commentary so we're going to be like
guys this website they may it will
probably check them on a factual basis
not on an opinion basis that's the right
way to do it yeah so but you know the
huffington post will get will get a
strike for an opinion piece because they
don't label anything as opinion when
they are but if a website says you know
the leading conservative opinion
and they're publishing fake news will be
like xxx you know we just won't hit him
for opinion stuff but that's important
too because a lot of people think when
they read like framing is big yeah
framing if it's something is falsely
framed that's opinion
so if it says like uh if they include
adjectives like donald trump
disgustingly referred to as a person by
this name that's an opinion absolutely
that adjective that framing device if
they say that you know donald trump took
a dangerous move today to do acts that's
an opinion if it says today donald trump
did a backflip that's a fact right i
mean he didn't literally do a backflip
but if the story is just like that
donald trump
boarded air force one he flew to this
place where he met with this person who
did this thing we say you're good
but if they say donald trump made a
disastrous attempt at meeting with a
dictator but
that's opinion
strike right
and i i think people will be surprised
how much is opinion oh absolutely i mean
i go to the new york times all the time
i can't get through the lead paragraph
without an opinion like 80 of the time
and so the new york times
i might get a score of like 10 out of
100. they almost always interject some
types of adjectival descriptions that
are not
factual or empirical it's some sort of
value judgment or moral
it's because it doesn't sell anymore and
that's why we want to do this nonprofit
so that we can be like
here's our summary of the site i'm i'm
less concerned about funding like news
guard wants to know who's funding you
i'm less concerned but let's read some
more of these super chats
all right let's see
benji
cole marez says please watch the video
creators shouldn't own their own
creations by unique name asaurus he
makes an amazing case for ending ip and
an alter alternative to our current
payment models it'll blow your mind tim
you should probably you should check
that out what's it called again creators
shouldn't own their creations
own their own creations
all right
on special noob says i spent an hour
last night trying to find shim cast on
google to become a member and support
the channel i'm calling bs it doesn't
exist it should be called sham cast not
[ __ ]
it should have been called
apparently yes sheamus said they call
him shim sham coghlin oh yeah i can see
it
oh right
mike pierce says have you heard about
oregon governor signing a bill to remove
proficient proficient proficiency exams
of reading writing and math to graduate
high school also will you have robert
barnes on the show he said he's willing
to come on we absolutely will have
robert bonds on the show we just have to
book him and so we will we will get that
sorted
um and yes i heard about oregon that uh
uh it's not about meritocracy anymore
it's about just
put them all in a little box and ship
them out
yeah um it's part of a patriarchal
system i believe and it's uh
because of a white system of oppression
so i guess and if you live in another
country and you have to take tests
there we're somehow internationally
imposing oppression abroad so i think
the japanese students they they still
have to do tests and
and chinese students they have to test
tests so i don't
yeah i'm not going to see it i'm not
quite following their argument
all right let's read this one uh fc3 uh
what does it say fc3s says ian is right
on ip why does a performer deserve more
for their work than your average
blue-collar worker if i fix a car i
don't charge every driver for the work
that i've done you create one widget you
get paid for one widget that's right if
i write one song
everybody who buys that song has to pay
me five dollars for it
but if you can make unlimited copies for
free then the supply increases x well
infinitely almost exponentially at the
very least so then shouldn't the value
the demand then decrease by that inverse
you know why
it's just the nature of economics no
that's for scarcity yeah you've
eliminated scarcity from amount of you
know
amount of songs you can copy yeah you
don't have to forge the cd and send it
out anymore but you it's it's it's your
property regardless of whether or not
you can make it easier the law says so
i'm just pointing out birdhouses are
really easy to make why don't we just
make it so that you have to give them
away if you have too many oh what's that
a surplus of corn you shouldn't be able
to do what you want with your property
you should have to give it bird houses
and corn are are like finite resources
when there's a surplus of corn but
that's still a finite resource the
digital copies can be done relatively
infinitely
so i don't think
it changes well it's changed the economy
that's what the whole argument is is the
piracy movement whatever you want to
call it i think of it more as just a
copy a copy fest i think i think the we
have this argument every so often where
ian thinks piracy is okay in terms of i
just don't think it's i don't think we
should call piracy i've heard that i
don't know if it's true that the fbi is
using calling it piracy and going after
them with international piracy laws
and and like treating them like actual
like people with weapons on boats that
are so that's the longest
sort of thing so so
my brother made an extremely viral video
that probably has a collective
multi-billion views
and his face isn't in it nor is his name
and it's been ripped off
like hunt thousands of times probably
and that's what's wrong with this
someone taking it and then re-hosting it
and making money off of someone else
people do do that with my content so and
i have to just approach them and say hey
stop using my yeah that's the same thing
jp some people stole his video uploaded
to facebook and that's how he got famous
and then he became super rich after that
yeah it's a good thing his face is a
name exactly see but that's not most
people most people aren't famous right
and a lot of art doesn't include the
name of the individual so stealing their
content and then repurposing it we call
it free booting and it's very it's it's
extremely detrimental to people i've
been trying to think of a technological
solution where like you could track
where the original came from and then
with the payments of the cryptocurrency
use smart contracts to automatically
divide the payment to the original
creator as well as any resalers
but as the way it looks i just see the
the inevitable economic restructure
because of the increase in supply
padre mortala says all right man what
the hell do you want people to do leave
cities not leave cities fight back not
fight back you really riled some
feathers in the my pillow video i'll
still watch but warily
um i've said it over and over again
leave cities when have i said don't
leave the cities i said i respect the
people who want to stay and fight back
but man when you're 20 of the vote
versus 80 of people who are burning it
down why would you stay there i've
repeatedly said if you're sitting in the
living room while the garage is on fire
and you're like i'm not going to leave
when the fire comes don't expect me to
come and shed a tear for you because you
chose to stay in a burning building so
yeah i think people should get out of
cities as for the the the my pillow
stuff
people
should be
riled up about all the changes that they
did in the voting in the voting laws
like in pennsylvania instead they're
they got the the you know the guy from
my pillow is telling them all this
grandiose stuff that he's never produced
the smoking gun for just anomalies i
admit the anomalies give me pause a lot
of them like the bellwether counties i'm
like that's very strange how does that
happen we should investigate and do
audits and i'm welcome for that but
outside of that
trying to draw definitive conclusion
from anomalies is impossible
so people could be right now saying we
we demand audits in these states in the
meantime we're going to work with the
republicans on voter reform instead
they're at a symposium and now the guy
comes out mike lindell's guy saying the
data was not good and he can't prove it
anyway and i'm like you see
you know what's really been bothering me
is
for all i know you know look there's
some smoking gun somewhere right
but ever since the election
i keep getting told
next week on monday
trump is going to come out and then
nothing happens i had a bunch of people
saying dude march 5th man
you're going to wait and see march 5th
and i'm like uh-huh sure nothing happens
then they're like no you know i'll come
july come august and i'm just like dude
i'm i i it's fine do whatever you want
to do
when there's a smoking gun when there's
hard evidence whatever do the audits do
all that stuff whatever builds your
confidence
but fighting back right now i think you
look at everything they did with
changing the voter laws and people are
distracted and they're not fighting back
yeah and i think that's very concrete
it's it's very much black and white for
me that they did not follow the
constitutionally
adopted process for
changing the
voter laws in the in these states
the issue to try to talk
to people about what the remedy is in
the solution is that they don't trust
elections to remedy this the republican
party has failed them they don't trust
them at all that in fact they hate
republicans because they don't stand up
for them are they betrayed
donald trump for their point of vie i
mean they loathe mike pence a lot of
these people or or governor kemp in
georgia
those people are villains to them they
feel completely let down by them and and
they feel like the system is
broken it's pardon me um what i would
point on this situation it was
essentially a red wave election in these
districts in house districts across the
united states
the house is a very key institution to
get in this in this current situation
that we're in you have to try to go and
get the house you have to try to make
tea party look like uh like a day at the
picnic in 2010 you need and and the the
democrats are going to be on the defense
i think they all know this um in in the
house races you have to
go out and try to make it happen and i
think like there is really literally no
way just prognosticating into the future
i don't think that there's a way that
the democrats hold on to the house it
just in taking the temperature of the
country and just all of the districts
around the united states it's just just
looking at a map of red and blue
counties um
it's it's just not it's just not going
to they're not going to hold on to the
house
in a fair election it's i don't think it
will happen well they're going to anger
a lot of parents um this fall it's true
but a year is a long time
it is a long time it's that last a week
is that last month you know what i mean
i don't think this i think this is going
to be a pressure cooker election i think
the crock pot is on the steam is
building i don't think it's
they're going to be looking for people
to blame for their miserable for
people's miserable lives which the
democrats are going to keep trying to
make us miserable uh you can bank on
that
and uh they're going to want to take it
out to some on somebody in the in the
polling booth if they comes out and all
these people turn out in mass and they
vote and somehow the democrats escape
leaving the house
uh
there's gonna be a real problem um i
just i you know we did not see mass
rioting after uh 2020. we saw the
january 6th incident um but we did not
see it at january 20th i mean what did
we see on january 20th when it was
predicted that there was going to be a
mass uprising we saw a few sad old
people with signs you know it you know
state capital buildings um but you did
not see the s h t f yet so um
i think people are holding out hope that
the midterms can give some course
corrections a lot of people
but some people have just left the
reservation they are not coming back and
they are looking to be more and more
angry and anybody that offers them some
chimeras to get angry about they're all
for it right now they're going to sit
they're going to um console themselves
and they're trying to go
wallow and sort of
self-pity to some point when they should
be organizing and being active and
looking for something substantive to
accomplish before the elections before
it's too late because the state
ultimately if you want to look at
somebody to be mad about for the 2020
election look at the state legislatures
these gop run state legislatures
completely dropped the ball they failed
their constituents they did not scream
bloody murder when these um absentee
ballot uh rules were changed without
their authority they did waited until it
was way too late to say anything about
it they should have jumped on it from
the very beginning they did not now they
want to do some kind of um
you know
you know
some after the fact sort of um
legislation that doesn't seem to go far
enough as you pointed out tim in some
cases and people hold them to the fire
hold yeah they're not paying attention
because they're distracted by these
other
side things and look i get it's a very
passionate subject and i'm not i'm look
i i understand a lot of people in my
audience they care about the subject and
i'm not
trying to talk down to you or anything
you're you're you have a right to be mad
you have a right to feel left out let
down by the system the election system
is broken
voter integrity is it is
in bad shape in this country we need to
look ahead for the sake of our kids and
our future not to fight the last war
fight the war ahead of you keep your eye
on the prize keep keep your eyes down
down range and focus on the concrete
things we could do because you don't let
your kids down
do something substantive vote for
the real
candidates not the not the establishment
republican types and then
when the new wave of populist right come
in you can impeach joe biden
for for all the ukraine stuff and the
china stuff launch all the subpoenas and
do all the
can you investigations focused man yeah
and and and i you know i'm i'm i'm
totally on board with that i mean
biden like we saw with the the the the
rent uh eviction moratorium that is
completely he knows it's
unconstitutional the supreme court said
it was completely illegal and he said
i'll do it anyway i guess broke his oath
of office right there if it was donald
trump they would be screaming bloody
murder in the media so don't just have a
long memory file all these things aboard
but in the meantime make sure the next
election has
not as much of a
[ __ ] show as the last one all right the
science change says excellent job on
mayogate seriously impressed with how
with how you're reporting what can an
average joe do to help america back get
back on track
raise your kids uh homeschool your kids
stand up for what you believe in make
hard choices and do hard things jordan
peterson says find the heaviest thing
you can carry and carry it i think that
would mean that if you're living in a
city where they're introducing things in
policy-wise that you don't agree with
and it's extremely difficult for you to
move
that must be the heaviest thing you can
carry and you probably should carry it
i think too many people just want
comfort the path of least resistance man
i love i love trudging through the storm
in the mud
i see that that that easy path oh it's a
real easy path for me i don't need to do
this job i could stop right now and i
can just skate all day and and do
whatever i could shut this show down why
should i deal with smears from the media
man it's brutal out there huh constantly
getting people sending me awful things
and threats and insults man who would
want to tread through something like
that that's the path of most resistance
well i like carrying heavy things i like
doing the hard work i could just i don't
know focus on the vlog the vlog will
make more than enough to just sustain me
for the rest of my i gotta worry about
anything build up that and do a
minecraft channel no i like the
challenge and that's why i'm here and
that's why i'm grateful to everybody
who's supporting that by being members
so i i think you know
at the very least sharing content
whether it be me or crowder or styx or
anybody that 6x9 or anybody you you
really like or checking out you know
kyle's website becker news and sharing
the things that you think are important
that's really that's an important thing
you know i know most of you do it all
the time
uh so
do what you can when you can i suppose
but i think maybe people need to realize
that you have to you have to carry
something heavier than you may be
carrying yeah speak your mind on the
internet make videos because it's
humiliating let people see who you are
for real let them know your fears and
what you've done let go of your secrets
and they'll trust you and then when you
when you tell them these things they'll
believe you
it's more powerful than voting for
people agreed i would say on a more
practical level to frequent small
businesses and go to family run
operations like that restaurant we
talked about earlier
ben stark says have you heard about tim
dillon and democrat media calling janmi
park a fraud thoughts i think they're
all liars i don't know about tim hill
and i don't watch his show but uh when i
when i show you that the democrat media
are lying to protect biden because it's
failed policies why would i believe them
on janmi park
i i saw one of the stories people were
like you go to see this tim she's a
fraud and then i saw her comment on it
and it was like a fairly reasonable
assessment you know what you know the
funny thing is man
people want to come out and insult her
and say all these things about her and i
read some of the criticisms of her i'm
like i think they're just out of context
smearing falsely framing because i'll
tell you this anybody who watches this
show who then goes and reads one of the
headpieces on me is going to laugh at
how insane they sound they're like i can
listen to this guy talk for four hours a
day and that does not represent what
that show is they're so desperate so the
mayo gate thing they would they 5.6
percent of inflation across the board
5.4 so they assumed that the mayo went
up by five point four yeah that's right
the mayo went up by a hundred percent
yeah not five point four percent but
these idiots these these fools
these lazy so it's false inductive it's
reasoning yeah right that's what it is
yeah yeah and then because they're all a
bunch of hooting midwits that they're
all like someone says that they'll go
yeah they're high-fiving each other and
chest bumping and it's like guys you're
so dumb
did you even call the restaurants i
don't like screaming idiot like what no
no no they don't have to be they are
supposed to call the restaurant you call
the restaurant when i saw the story i
went i googled the website i grew the
restaurant i put the phone called it
within a minute a guy says hello and i'm
like hi my name is tim paul i'm a
journalist i'm trying to get a comment
on this story about mayonnaise and
elantra's like oh yeah uh
what do you need i just see that it says
here you pay 200 more per week in
mayonnaise and i was wondering if you
could uh elaborate on how that is oh
yeah so we we do about 10 buckets per
week it's five gallons each they used to
cost about 18 bucks now they're about 36
so you do the math it's about 10 more
buckets so it's about 200 bucks and i
went
sounds about right to me what's your
what's your restaurant capacity 250. and
he says and we and we use the mayonnaise
for our dressings and stuff in the
sausages and i'm like 100 increase in
that cost makes sense to me dude yeah
completely we know that we don't miss i
mean that is not even like you barely
almost hit it you completely missed it
and they double down they completely
three different writers and now they're
driving a harassment campaign at a small
business who said nothing political
these this is it's not journalism that's
the problem i went to school for
journalism for a period for like a year
it you learn about citing sources about
seeking multiple sources fact checking
looking getting an editor to go through
your stuff afterwards did you see and
then putting your face behind it that's
a big part of it you see the daily beast
wrote where they were like six months on
donald trump his
staffers are urging him to promote the
vaccine but he says no
and it's like it says nope it's got a
big trump mouth and i'm just like
yo i get so many emails from trump where
he's like the vaccine is mine it's the
greatest vaccine everyone should get it
it's safe that's right he's like there's
one email i went through my email of all
the emails from trump and it's like
trump's not getting credit for the
vaccine and he's like they're trying to
claim credit for the work i did it's
safe everyone should get it i'm like
how did they write an article claiming
trump won't promote the vaccine when he
won't shut up about it i know he talks
about operation worse warp speed is the
greatest thing since you know the you
know the uh the attack on okinawa and
world war ii you know i mean like won't
give him credit and he yeah he wants the
credit give me the credit i know that's
donald trump's personality i mean come
on all right let's see we got here
ramsay stripling says some woman tried
to come in the restaurant i work at with
a regular non-service dog didn't allow
her in and she got all of her friends to
write reviews calling us racist and
discriminatory brought overall review
down four point eight two three can we
like okay yelp you companies google that
do these at restaurant reviews can you
make it so that they have to have a geo
locator go off when they're in the
restaurant or something where they got
to log in
like the restaurant has something with
your website where they got to log in it
doesn't work so to verify that they're
eating there i mean what this is someone
across down the road can vote i knew a
restaurant is a burger joint and they
got a call from yelp and they were like
hey you know we see you on the site and
we want to reach out to you so if you
want to do any advertising with us and
he was like i'm not interested okay
all of a sudden a bunch of bad reviews
started coming in
and he you know there are some people
who allege there's a conspiracy or
whatever but what was happening was bad
reviews would come in and the good
reviews weren't coming in
and it was because they said well the
people who uh are
in the restaurant having a bad
experience pick it up and go
and the people have a good experience
don't say anything and then later on
they might be like oh yeah you know i
went to that restaurant that was cool
and then they're like well this one is
real time this one's not the point is
it's not so easy just to just to
geofence but isn't the problem here that
people across the country are down
voting a restaurant that makes no sense
how do you prove that you've been there
and you don't put like a bar code on the
receipt that you got to scan or
something before you leave the
restaurant
how about you can only review it if you
have a current receipt
there you go i like that easy yeah
all right
kamikaze a says australia is tracking
population via qr codes we're required
to enter our details and phone number to
get a verification code to be able to
enter any business anyone looking to
adopt a few aussies
come on over it's uh it's it's man
what do you call it when all of these
countries are moving in the exact same
direction you can't travel between them
and uh i don't know global
authoritarianism yeah wow international
fascism new world order i don't know
you're all right
smiley face
richard cranium says tim i work in
long-term care bet you can't guess the
party that comes in to do absentee
voting i'll give you a hint
yep
napalm bonerfart says hot take parents
should send their kids to the military
best thing to happen to me i turned left
to right but mostly learned
responsibility good i don't think i i
i don't think you can do that
like your kid turns 18 they leave
i do think there's like military
academies and stuff and schools you can
go to and uh i'm i
am um
service guarantees citizenship is the
easiest way to say it i don't i don't
know if a military academy or the
military is is the way to do it no it's
not but the romans tried that no i mean
if you have a wayward kid they're not
gonna find themselves in the military
they need to want to do it and if they
don't want to do it it's not going to
work out so well for them probably you
are correct my brother really wanted to
join the military and my parents didn't
want him to but he did and it was great
for him yeah whereas with my other
brother he didn't really like it he got
out as soon as he could it's like 50 50.
it's it's whatever you make of it yeah
don't go to the military as a way of
avoiding work or whatever just like work
for a while and really think about it
and then if you feel like you need to
get our orders barked to you and you
need to go serve
you know just be ready for it and go get
it you know
the one-eyed king says tim should
rittenhouse trust truth as an
affirmative defense like you said
lindell should with the dominion suit
the dominion suit is a civil lawsuit
where they're alleging he said things
that were not the truth and that have
caused them financial damages for which
they are trying to recover financial
damages
in the instance of a defamation suit
there's something called an affirmative
defense meaning i told the truth case
dismissed and all he need do is go to
the judge and say here you are your
honor there's the evidence and the judge
will say case dismissed that's it
without written it's a criminal trial
and you're going to have an adversarial
court where the state tries to prove
their case and the defense tries to
prove their case but still i would say
yes cobra now should rely on the truth
to win
granted you'll need really good lawyers
because they're going to use
manipulative tactics but the truth shall
set you free my bigger bigger issue i
suppose is that politics will play a
role and it doesn't matter whether or
not
he's uh he's right or wrong in the
instance of dominion and uh lindell it's
entirely possible the judge would not
rule in favor of lindell no matter what
but if that's the case then what are you
trying to prove if if no matter what you
do no one will ever accept it because
they're scared socially you've got a
culture problem and all you're doing is
preaching to the choir
well maybe that's what he's trying to do
with the cyber symposium just to play
devil's advocate here
he's trying to persuade people and and
you know use the media to
spread his message and um
you know maybe he feels like the courts
aren't a fair venue for him you know
maybe he personally feels that
i'm not you know i don't represent his
legal team and i don't know all of the
thinking and strategy behind it but
that's definitely historically
functional getting the crowd behind you
is a powerful way to bypass the courts
and the courts will vote for you yep
beaumarchet did it in france got out of
a civil lawsuit
happy says do you think there is a place
for libertarian leaning people who are
socially liberal in the classical sense
for the most part i'm pretty socially
liberal however i don't like big
government
yeah i agree that's like the usual left
libertarian position but uh
i don't know what to tell you man our
institutions are all completely
corporatist
what do you do well look at look at
blackrock's infiltration of of the biden
government the economic advisors like
you know mike pyle with kamal kamala
harris who was also put in neo-liberal
policies under obama um
you know you you look at what west
exactly i was shocked actually that one
of these think tanks that was
it was formed uh that basically sells
itself as this sort of
white house
uh
pr crisis management team there's like
23
from this one think tank sort of
organization in the biden white house
and then you have a very weak president
in this mix who doesn't seem to be
running the show
it strikes me as very corporatist and
very cd yeah ladies and gentlemen smash
that like button if you have not already
and go to timcast.com become a member so
you can check out the members podcast
which should be up around 11 or so p.m
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me personally at tim cast
is there anything you wanted to shout
out kyle no just uh follow me on twitter
you know i will likely be doing a
podcast in the future if you want to
keep an eye out for that that would be
great um but uh just uh really enjoyed
being here with tim i mean it was a
pleasure it was great to see his studio
and everything he's got going on here
seems to be going in a great direction
so
what's your twitter handle kyle and a
backer and a becker yeah thanks for
coming man that was great yeah that was
fun actually thanks a lot again
you guys can follow me also at ian
crossland.net or at ian crossland on
social media and you rock
you guys can follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids as i continue my adventure
trying to get more followers and sour
patch kids
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for the members segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you